My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay.
我叫亚娜，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。书中关于各种不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容让我觉得非常有趣。令我惊讶的是，通往这一职业的道路竟有如此之多，而且并没有所谓的“完美路径”。这让我感到自信，意识到我并没有走错路，也减轻了我的心理压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你读读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。
But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. from someone who's committed a crime and real story isn't about evil but about trauma. Today's guest King's Council barrister Chris Dorr has spent decades inside courtrooms and prisons and what he's learned will completely change how you think about crime, punishment and justice. Together we're exploring the uncomfortable truth that our justice system often punishes pain instead of healing it. and why we keep getting that wrong. Hope you find it super useful. If you do, please like and subscribe for more.
但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。故事的主人公曾犯下罪行，但真实的故事并非关于邪恶，而是关于创伤。今天的嘉宾，御用大律师克里斯·多尔（Chris Dorr）在法庭和监狱里度过了几十年，他的见解将彻底改变你对犯罪、惩罚和正义的看法。我们将共同探讨一个令人不安的事实：我们的司法系统往往是在惩罚痛苦，而不是治愈痛苦，以及为什么我们在这方面总是犯错。希望你觉得这期节目非常有价值。如果喜欢，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。
Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist, and I'm joined here today by Chris Dore Casey. Hi, Chris, welcome along. Hi, good morning. Thank you so much for being here. I followed you like a little LinkedIn creep for probably over five years now.
大家好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天和我一起的是克里斯·多尔（Chris Dorr）御用大律师。你好，克里斯，欢迎来到这里。你好，早上好。非常感谢你能来。我像个LinkedIn上的小跟踪狂一样关注你大概有五年多了。
And I'm so pleased that you've agreed to come on the podcast because I honestly think everybody should know about you and about your work and your incredible book, Justice, on trial. So thank you for being here. Not at all. I'm very excited. And also my daughter is an aspiring psychologist, so I think I'm in the right place. Oh, perfect. Well, I didn't know that.
我非常高兴你能同意参加这个播客，因为我真心认为每个人都应该了解你、你的工作以及你那本不可思议的书——《正义在审判中》（Justice on Trial）。所以，谢谢你的到来。别客气，我非常兴奋。而且，我的女儿也是一名有抱负的心理学家，所以我认为我来对地方了。哦，太完美了。我之前不知道这一点。
But yeah, do shove her our way. So we will go on to think a little bit about what a case even is, but maybe that's not our strongest opener. Could you tell us a little bit about perhaps why justice is a bit broken, Chris? Yeah, I mean, it's because we are obsessed with the idea that you can punish your way out of criminality. And so we have this kind of ever increasing a sort of ratchet effect when it comes to abuse of incarceration and imprisonment, which the Americans have taken to the ultimate degree almost, of having two and a half million people in their prisons around the US.
好的，一定要把她介绍给我们。接下来我们想探讨一下什么是“案件”，但这可能不是最好的开场白。克里斯，你能告诉我们为什么正义在某种程度上是破碎的吗？是的，这是因为我们沉迷于一种观念，即可以通过惩罚来消除犯罪。因此，在滥用监禁和囚禁方面，我们有一种不断升级的“棘轮效应”。美国人几乎将其发挥到了极致，全国监狱里关押着250万人。
I mean, we're at sort of approaching 100,000. So even sort of pro rata, we're still not there yet. But the prison population has doubled in my career of 30 years as a criminal lawyer from sort of mid-40thous 90 and then heading towards 100,000. So it's really that simple. We genuinely as a society, whether we believe it or not, or whether politicians just dissuade us enough that it's a good idea at election time. But we genuinely believe that if you keep on punishing and increasing the amount of time you sentence people to in prison and the long time they spend in prison,
我们的监狱人口接近10万人。所以即使按比例计算，我们还没达到那个程度。但在我作为刑事律师的30年职业生涯中，监狱人口已经翻了一番，从4万多增加到现在的近10万人。所以道理很简单。作为一个社会，无论我们是否相信，或者政客们在选举时是否足够说服我们这是个好主意，我们确实相信，如果你不断惩罚，增加人们的刑期，延长他们在监狱里的时间，
that that's going to magically transform our society into a lower crime society and somehow or other it's going to put people off committing crime. And, you know, anyone who knows anything about human psychology and particularly the psychology of those who are who get themselves caught up in the justice system, in particular when there is young teenagers, that kind of age, will know that, you know, simply punishing people, relentlessly punishing them more and more, isn't going to solve anything because the vast majority of the people who are going into prisons have deep-rooted traumas, deep-rooted histories of abuse, you know, in their childhoods or witnessing terrible things happening or, you know, major psychiatric conditions or addictions and so forth. So it's pretty obvious, it seems to me, it's a matter of common sense, that you can't imprison your way out of psychological and psychiatric trauma because you know you're just going to make it worse and
这就能奇迹般地将我们的社会转变为一个低犯罪率的社会，并以某种方式阻止人们犯罪。你知道，任何了解人类心理学，特别是了解那些卷入司法系统的人（尤其是十几岁的青少年）的心理的人都会知道，仅仅惩罚人们，无休止地加重惩罚，是解决不了任何问题的。因为绝大多数进入监狱的人都有根深蒂固的创伤、受虐待的历史，或者目睹过可怕的事情，或者患有严重的精神疾病、成瘾等。所以在我看来，这显而易见，这只是常识问题：你无法通过监禁来解决心理和精神创伤，因为你知道这只会让情况变得更糟，
therefore the people who are put through that come out and on the whole are even more broken than when they went in and sadly even less likely to be able to engage lawfully in society and productively in society so we just keep making the same mistake we keep making it in in ever greater proportions in the sense that sentences get longer and longer and longer and you know it isn't achieving anything except wasting a lot of money and perhaps even more sadly, wasting a lot of human life. Yeah, I absolutely believe. I agree with everything you're saying.
因此，经历过这些的人出来后，总体上比进去时更加破碎，遗憾的是，他们更难在社会中合法且富有成效地生活。所以我们一直在犯同样的错误，而且规模越来越大，刑期越来越长。这除了浪费大量金钱，或许更令人悲哀的是，浪费了许多宝贵的生命，并没有取得任何成果。是的，我完全相信。我同意你所说的一切。
And I think there's so many parallels, isn't there? There's getting tough as a parent and there's getting tough as a school and dishing out punishments and dishing out, you know, all these detentions. And they just don't mean anything, you know? It happens so often. I've seen it happening in my own family. There's members of kids in my family, teenagers who have had real troubles at school. And they just keep getting excluded and sent home.
我认为有很多相似之处，不是吗？作为父母或学校，采取强硬手段，施加惩罚，给予各种留校察看。这些根本没有任何意义，你知道吗？这种情况经常发生。我在自己的家庭中也见过。我家里有几个十几岁的孩子在学校遇到了真正的麻烦。他们只是不断地被开除和送回家。
and hold off and you know it just doesn't well I'm not sure what the point of it is you see I mean I think the reason I kind of came to writing and particular writing justice on trial was because I was I kind of fed up with just just doing the same thing it was like a hamster in a wheel at work every day going to court case court doing a case and the process kind of run the system so so you just do it because that's the system and then the problem for me is that I started to say to myself, well, we keep doing it, but it's actually making it worse, not better. So I took a blank sheet of paper, traveled all over the world, looked at the way that prison works in other countries, looked at way that other sort of criminal justice policies operate, and decided
然后被拒之门外，你知道，我真的不明白这有什么意义。我认为我之所以开始写作，特别是写《正义在审判中》，是因为我厌倦了每天做同样的事情。就像每天在轮子里奔跑的仓鼠，去法庭、处理案件、走流程，系统就是这样运作的，所以你只是因为这是系统要求而去做。对我来说，问题在于我开始对自己说，我们一直在这样做，但实际上情况变得更糟了，而不是更好。所以我拿出一张白纸，走遍世界各地，观察其他国家的监狱运作方式，观察其他刑事司法政策的运作方式，并决定
to, you know, write a book that just with a blank sheet of paper said, this is what you could actually do to make things better, reduce crime, make society safer, and save us billions of pounds a year, which all of which seemed like very good ideas to me, none of which are being adopted in any significant way by any government, certainly not in the UK and certainly not in the US. Well, I think it should be and, you know, I still think we need to keep beating that drum because I think it's a really inspiring, really interesting book. And I think another parallel that's really interesting is you speak about being a very similar age to someone who kind of is really on the wrong tracks and is in all kinds of strife. And you're almost
写一本书，用一张白纸说：这就是你可以做的，以改善现状、减少犯罪、让社会更安全，并每年为我们节省数十亿英镑。这些在我看来都是非常好的主意，但没有任何政府（当然在英国和美国都没有）以任何重要的方式采纳它们。嗯，我认为应该采纳，而且我认为我们仍然需要不断敲响警钟，因为我认为这是一本非常鼓舞人心、非常有趣的书。还有一个有趣的相似之处是，你提到你和一个正处于歧途、陷入各种困境的人年龄相仿。你几乎
curious, before we met, we were speaking about the fact that we actually grew up, you know, a few miles away from each other. And Milton Keynes is not known for its, you know, its success rates perhaps for young people. But you've done, you know, people that are watching on YouTube will be able to see your marvellous garden and hear the birds. People who are listening might be like, what is what is all that birds? Is he recording in an aviary? But, you know, you've done well for yourself. But you perhaps could have had a different path yourself yeah I mean it's it's an interesting one because you know my life kind of took a fork in the road when I was 16 and it and it could have taken a completely different fork in the road because I'd largely been the sort of a school refusor if you like that but not in the not in the same I mean I just bumped off a lot and no and back in the 80s nobody really checked whether you were at school or not certainly not where I went to school I'm sure they did a lot of schools but not at mine
在见面之前，我们谈到我们实际上是在离彼此几英里的地方长大的。米尔顿凯恩斯（Milton Keynes）可能并不以其年轻人的成功率而闻名。但你已经做到了，YouTube上的观众可以看到你美妙的花园并听到鸟叫声。听众可能会想：这些鸟叫声是怎么回事？他是在鸟舍里录音吗？但你确实取得了成功。但你可能本可以走上一条不同的道路。是的，这是一个有趣的话题，因为我16岁时人生出现了一个分叉路口，它本可以走向一条完全不同的道路。因为我基本上是个逃学者，但我只是经常逃课，而在80年代，没人真的检查你是否在学校，至少在我上的学校是这样。我相信很多学校会检查，但我的学校没有。
and so being absent nobody really cared i mean the schools were so um overcrowded there were so many kids in the classes the academic attainment was so low that it was kind of like the expectations were just on the floor which meant that you know if you if you'd even read a book that was quite impressive you know um and so so compared to the education that my kids have for example it was completely um it was completely sort of non-existent from a form in a formal sense but i think because of my personality type which is quite independent and and and and actually has always been an addictive and obsessive reader. And that was the key.
所以缺席也没人关心。学校太拥挤了，班里有那么多孩子，学术水平太低，以至于期望值简直低到了尘埃里。这意味着如果你读过一本书，那都相当令人印象深刻。所以与我孩子所受的教育相比，从正式意义上讲，我的教育几乎是不存在的。但我认为，因为我的性格类型——相当独立，而且一直是一个沉迷于阅读的人。这就是关键。
So the fact that I read independently from a very young age, my mum taught me to read the two, three years of age, even before nursery. And that to me, I think, is what kind of allowed me later to kind of embark on education and for the first time to see the value of education. But that was only because of a set of circumstances that took me to a really good six-form college when I was 16.
所以，我从很小的时候就开始独立阅读，我妈妈在我两三岁、甚至上幼儿园之前就教我识字了。我认为，正是这一点让我后来能够开始接受教育，并第一次看到了教育的价值。但这仅仅是因为一系列机缘巧合，让我在16岁时进入了一所非常好的预科学校（sixth-form college）。
Whereas had I either stayed in Milton Keynes where I grew up Or had I, you know, I actually left home to go and sell donuts in the south of France on the beach at the age of 16. Had that been a big success and your listeners may be surprised to know that it wasn't, but had it been a big success, who knows, I could be the donut king of Nice or something like that instead. And I think everybody has these forks in the road and mine just happened to take you to a good sixth form college. And we live there with a gardener, back then, but it took me to a good sixth form college. And it took me to, ultimately, to Manchester University, which was a great law school, great university and, of course, an incredible city to live in.
如果我留在长大的米尔顿凯恩斯，或者如果我16岁时离开家去法国南部的海滩卖甜甜圈，如果那是一个巨大的成功——听众可能会惊讶地发现它并不是——但如果它是一个巨大的成功，谁知道呢，我可能现在是尼斯的甜甜圈大王之类的。我认为每个人都有这些人生分叉路口，而我的路口恰好把我带到了一所好的预科学校。我们当时住在那里，但它把我带到了一所好的预科学校。最终把我带到了曼彻斯特大学，那是一所很棒的法学院，很棒的大学，当然，也是一个令人难以置信的城市。
And I ended up spending almost 20 years living and working in Manchester. And that, to me, was the best thing that could have happened to me. Yeah. And, you know, I think you clearly had family that it was safe to come back to and a safe, stable base. And, you know, you were taught to read. And, you know, that wasn't ridiculed. You know, that was seen as actually a good thing for Chris to be doing. And a lot of the young people that I work with, for example, in a youth prison,
我最终在曼彻斯特生活和工作了近20年。对我来说，那是可能发生在我身上最好的事情。是的，而且我认为你显然有一个安全的家庭可以回去，有一个安全、稳定的基础。而且，你被教导阅读，那并没有被嘲笑。那被视为克里斯在做一件好事。而我工作中的许多年轻人，例如在青少年监狱里，
if on the day that you are born or discharged from hospital, your parents leave you in a car seat on the steps of the firehouse and go off and do a drugs run, like your chances to succeed are dramatically reduced, right? Well, I can tell you a direct story that kind of illustrates that point. from my school life in Milton Keynes because what happened there was a young boy I won't give his name but there's a boy who's very young boy same age as me who's in my class and he always had sort of like clothes that looked like they'd been I don't know they didn't fit him and and and he always like looked at very sort of struthy and a bit unkempt and so forth and he got quite badly bullied and I and I would and I would sort of chat to him and sort of befriend him a little bit and one day I got called into the office at school and um um and asked to come come in and Kevin sorry i shouldn't give his name anyway doesn't matter i'll give his second name um kevin was in there um and he had all his hair had sort of been chopped off and what happened was kevin had taken some books home from the library and his dad had battered him because he said why are you wasting
如果你出生或出院的那天，你的父母把你留在消防站台阶上的汽车座椅里，然后去进行毒品交易，那么你成功的机会就会大大降低，对吧？我可以告诉你一个直接的故事来说明这一点。在我米尔顿凯恩斯的学校生活中，发生过一件事：有一个小男孩，我不会说出他的名字，但他是一个非常年轻的男孩，和我同班。他总是穿着看起来不合身的衣服，看起来总是很邋遢，有点不修边幅，他被欺负得很厉害。我会和他聊天，和他交朋友。有一天，我被叫到学校办公室，
your effing time with books you know you want to do something more useful with you life and he cut all his hair off as a punishment for bringing books home so i mean if you think about that i mean i was very lucky as you say my mom was a big reader and still is um and she was obsessed with sort of reading in particular was it was I think was her kind of escape from an education that hadn't been particularly successful and and so she was a sort of self-taught in many ways and and that that it was only that pure good fortune to have parents who who were both encouraging and supportive but also who were hands off enough to let me sort of make mistakes find things out for myself learn things that I wanted to learn and weren't too
被要求进去。凯文——抱歉，我不该说出他的名字，没关系，我还是说他的姓吧——凯文在里面。他的头发被剪掉了。发生的事情是，凯文从图书馆带了一些书回家，他爸爸打了他，因为他说：“你为什么要把该死的时间浪费在书本上？你应该做点更有用的事情。”他剪掉了他所有的头发，作为带书回家的惩罚。所以，如果你想想看，我非常幸运，正如你所说，我妈妈是一个狂热的读者，现在依然是。我认为阅读是她逃避一种并不成功的教育的方式。
obsessed with what I was doing at school as being the most important thing they could see that there's value in reading for its own sake and it's It almost doesn't matter what you read, so long as you read something and you expand your thinking, your mind. So very, very lucky, in contrast to Paul Kevin, who suffered a completely different fate and was physically abused simply for bringing books home from school. And that tells you why some people in our society have good fortune and others don't, regardless of money or anything else. It's all to do with that home environment and whether there's a broad kind of support for the child's development and welfare and education. If there is, as I was lucky enough,
所以她在很多方面是自学的。正是那种纯粹的好运，让我拥有既鼓励和支持我，又足够放手让我犯错、自己发现事物、学习我想学的东西的父母。他们并没有太执着于我在学校的表现，认为那是最重要的事。他们能看到阅读本身就有价值，而且读什么几乎不重要，只要你阅读并扩展你的思维和头脑。所以我非常非常幸运，与可怜的凯文形成鲜明对比，他仅仅因为从学校带书回家就受到了身体虐待。这说明了为什么我们社会中的一些人有好运，而另一些人没有，这与金钱或其他任何东西无关。这完全取决于家庭环境，以及是否对孩子的成长、福利和教育有广泛的支持。如果有，就像我足够幸运那样，
was the case for me, then, you know, the potential, even in an area or in a school that's an underperforming school, the potential's still there. But if you don't have any of that, and in fact, if you have positive pushback against that, your life chances really are going to be very, very long. Yeah, poor Kevin. That is like, honestly, that's like Mr. Wormwood from Matilda, isn't it? Like, that's Roald Dahl's most horrendous creation, but that's come to real life. I was thinking the other day, like my kids don't realize how lucky they are. I've got two of them, but they don't realize how lucky they are, that they don't need to be at school wondering what mood mummy or daddy is going to be in when they get home or wondering whether
那么，即使在表现不佳的地区或学校，潜力依然存在。但如果你没有任何支持，事实上，如果你有积极的阻力，你的人生机会真的会非常非常渺茫。是的，可怜的凯文。这简直就像《玛蒂尔达》里的沃姆伍德先生，对吧？就像罗尔德·达尔最可怕的创作，但却在现实生活中发生了。我前几天还在想，我的孩子们没有意识到他们有多幸运。我有两个孩子，但他们没有意识到他们有多幸运，他们不需要在学校里担心回家时妈妈或爸爸会是什么心情，或者担心
mummy's going to be sober. I actually don't drink at all anymore. And that's not because it's been problematic. It's just to think I'm just, I just don't need it. But, you know, they don't, they don't need to be thinking, oh, is she quit for now or is she quit for good? You know, am I going to have to go home and pick, you know, mop up her vomit or, you know, How can you be able to learn and to focus on that if you've got all of that in your mind? And these are some of the people that you end up working within the justice system because they're having to be, you know, they've been parentified or they're just having to, I don't know, go out and steal things to even have food to put on the table for their families.
妈妈是否会清醒。我实际上已经完全不喝酒了。这并不是因为喝酒有问题，只是觉得我不需要它。但是，他们不需要担心：“哦，她现在清醒吗？还是她彻底清醒了？”你知道，我回家后是不是得去清理她的呕吐物？如果你的脑子里装满了这些，你怎么能学习和专注呢？这些人就是你最终在司法系统中工作时会遇到的人，因为他们不得不变得“成人化”，或者他们只是不得不出去偷东西，甚至是为了给家人弄点吃的。
Like it just isn't fair, is it? It's not, it's not, we're not all starting from the same point in life. No, I mean, and has it ever been any different? I mean, since time began, you know, we've had vast inequalities of wealth, vast inequalities in access to education, vast inequalities in access to health, healthcare and safety. You know, it's very easy, isn't it, for us in what, the fourth or fifth richest country in the world, to get, you know, to kind of come up with these ideas of how awful it is. And it is awful for many young people in our country. But if you take a global perspective, and you kind of look out a little bit more from our little island and you realize the, conditions in which people live in other countries and we're seeing what's happening uh you know in the middle east and and of course you know extraordinary um problems in africa and and and all sorts of other places all over the world where you know the levels of kind of inequality poverty and and cruelty towards large sections of the population are so extraordinary it's to be unimaginable and you know i i guess in the end because you can't solve all the problems you just
这太不公平了，不是吗？我们并不是都从人生的同一起跑线上出发的。不，我的意思是，情况曾经不同过吗？自古以来，我们就存在巨大的财富不平等、受教育机会的不平等、医疗保健和安全机会的不平等。你知道，对于我们这些生活在世界上第四或第五富有国家的人来说，很容易想出这些关于现状有多糟糕的想法。对于我们国家的许多年轻人来说，这确实很糟糕。但如果你从全球视角来看，稍微跳出我们这个小岛，你就会意识到其他国家人们的生活条件。我们看到了在中东发生的事情，当然还有非洲以及世界各地所有其他地方的非凡问题，那里的人们所面临的不平等、贫困和对大部分人口的残酷程度是如此惊人，简直无法想象。你知道，我想最终，因为你无法解决所有问题，你只能
to have to use whatever sort of skill set you have, whatever knowledge you have, to try to make a difference in some way to something. Because if everyone did that, if everyone did a little bit of something to try and make a little bit of difference, then of course the cumulative effect will be extraordinary. The difficulty is that most people, understandably in many cases, live entirely in their own bubble and totally self-focused on what their own needs are and their own wants, particularly in wealthy countries. And, you know, in the end, if selfishness is the guiding principle behind most people's lives and most people's sort of outlook, then you're going to end up with a selfish and very unequal world and a deeply unfair world. So to answer your question,
利用你拥有的任何技能、任何知识，试图以某种方式做出改变。因为如果每个人都这样做，如果每个人都做一点点努力去尝试做出一点点改变，那么累积效应将是惊人的。困难在于，大多数人（在许多情况下是可以理解的）完全生活在自己的泡沫中，完全专注于自己的需求和欲望，特别是在富裕国家。最终，如果自私是大多数人生活和展望背后的指导原则，那么你最终会得到一个自私、非常不平等且极其不公平的世界。所以回答你的问题，
yes, it's unfair, but it is inevitable. There's going to be some level of unfairness. The question is what, as an individual, what are you going to do about? Yeah, absolutely. It's reminding me of kind of part of our conversation earlier, but also in your book, you speak about the number of incarcerated people in each country actually on paper becomes to be, if you equated it to the number of people in a city, that actually incarceration city is kind of massive and some of the biggest cities in the world. Yeah, well, it was the US in particular that I was talking about. So if you take that US prison population of give or take two and a half million, it certainly was that at the time that I wrote the book, then that would have been the fifth largest city in the
是的，这不公平，但这是不可避免的。总会有某种程度的不公平。问题是，作为一个个体，你打算对此做些什么？是的，绝对是。这让我想起了我们之前谈话的一部分，但在你的书中，你谈到每个国家的监禁人数，如果按城市人口计算，实际上“监禁之城”规模巨大，是世界上一些最大的城市。是的，我特别提到的是美国。所以，如果你以我写书时大约250万的美国监狱人口计算，那将是美国第五大城市。
United States. I think Houston was thought was was was fourth and you have New York, LA and Chicago and then Houston and then prison and two and a half million people in prison is a quite extraordinary number just to get your head around that number. I mean that that is that is far bigger than Birmingham far bigger than Manchester. You know this is that's an extraordinary number of people and you know they do live effectively in the albeit some of them are in New York and some of them in California, but effectively, they all live pretty much in the same basic ecosystem of, you know, just relentless rolling door, incarceration, being constantly on some sort of court supervision which they can then break and then get sent back to prison and then go
我想休斯顿是第四，你有纽约、洛杉矶和芝加哥，然后是休斯顿，然后是监狱。250万人被关在监狱里，这是一个相当惊人的数字，光是理解这个数字就很困难。我的意思是，这比伯明翰大得多，比曼彻斯特大得多。你知道，这是一个惊人的数字。而且，他们实际上生活在——尽管有些人是在纽约，有些人是在加利福尼亚——但实际上，他们都生活在同一个基本的生态系统中，即无休止的旋转门式监禁，不断受到某种法庭监督，然后他们可能会违反规定，然后被送回监狱，然后再次
again for longer and longer. You know, it is a quite extraordinary thing to have created a world in which two and a half million people in the richest country in the world are incarcerated. I mean, it's quite extraordinary. Yeah, it really is. And clearly getting tough on crime doesn't work there either. Well, because they're not getting tough on crime. If you're getting tough on something, say if you want to get tough on cancer, you don't beat the patient with a stick.
被关更长的时间。你知道，创造一个世界上最富有的国家里有250万人被监禁的世界，这是一件相当惊人的事情。我的意思是，这太惊人了。是的，确实如此。显然，对犯罪采取强硬态度在那里也不起作用。嗯，因为他们并没有对犯罪采取强硬态度。如果你想对某事采取强硬态度，比如你想对癌症采取强硬态度，你不会用棍子打病人。
What you do to get tough on cancer is you find the cleverest medications, the cleverest therapies and the cleverest treatments, and you relentlessly apply logic, good practice, pragmatism and expertise to curing the cancer. You don't simply say, well, this person's got cancer, we're going to hit them until the cancer's gone and that's effectively metaphorically what we do with people are with our criminal justice system we take people with a serious and significant trauma coming from childhood or coming through their young lives who then you know don't
你对癌症采取强硬态度的做法是找到最聪明的药物、最聪明的疗法和最聪明的治疗方法，并不断地将逻辑、良好的实践、实用主义和专业知识应用于治愈癌症。你不会简单地说：“好吧，这个人得了癌症，我们要打他们直到癌症消失。”这实际上就是我们在刑事司法系统中对人们所做的隐喻。我们对待那些来自童年或年轻生活中遭受严重创伤的人，他们然后
engage properly with education do end up often in the hands of either gangs or other sort of criminal enterprises or sometimes you know assisting in crime in some way and then they get themselves arrested often in their teens and they get themselves in front of a youth thought some of them go to a young offenders institution and essentially from that point onwards you may as well tattoo criminal on their forehead because their life chances are about as high as if you were to wander around looking like that and as a society you know every time there's an election you know we have you know the government you know the parties can are arguing about which one's going to lock people up for the longest we're going to give even longer sentences we're going to get tougher but that's
没有适当地接受教育，最终往往落入帮派或其他犯罪企业手中，或者有时以某种方式协助犯罪，然后他们在十几岁时被捕，出现在青少年法庭面前，有些人去了青少年管教所。从那一刻起，你不如在他们额头上纹上“罪犯”二字，因为他们的人生机会就像那样走来走去一样高。作为一个社会，你知道，每次选举时，政府和政党都在争论谁会把人关得最久，我们要判更长的刑期，我们要更强硬。但这就是
the problem the terminology of toughness has become completely distorted because for me being tough means using your brain power and your energy to aggressively try and solve a problem, that's toughness. Toughness is not hitting the most vulnerable people time and time again with long prison sentences at vast public expense, only to make the fundamental problem that you're trying to address even worse than it was before you did it. And at its most simplest, it comes down to it does it not? Which is, what's the point of criminal justice? Why do we have a criminal justice system? Now, lots of people, their initial answer would be, to punish people who break the law.
问题所在，强硬的术语已经完全扭曲了。因为对我来说，强硬意味着利用你的脑力和精力去积极地尝试解决问题，那才是强硬。强硬不是一次又一次地用长期的监禁来打击最脆弱的人，还要花费巨大的公共开支，结果只是让你试图解决的根本问题比你做之前更糟。最简单地说，不是吗？那就是：刑事司法的意义是什么？我们为什么要有刑事司法系统？现在，很多人最初的回答是：惩罚那些违法的人。
That would be their answer, okay? The problem with that analysis is, if you do that, what happens next when you punish the people who broke the law? If you punish them in the most aggressive and, you know, they talk about rude, take away their televisions, their base stations, don't let them have all this, make them solitary confinement 24 hours, make it horrible. The consequence of that is that they're going to commit a lot more crimes
那会是他们的回答，对吧？这种分析的问题在于，如果你这样做，当你惩罚了违法的人之后，接下来会发生什么？如果你以最激进的方式惩罚他们，你知道，他们谈论的是粗鲁，拿走他们的电视、基站，不让他们拥有这些，让他们24小时单独监禁，让它变得可怕。这样做的后果是，他们会犯下更多的罪行，
for a lot longer and a lot worse crime. But if you're happy with that, you stick with that plan, of just constantly making your sentences longer and your prison conditions harder. For me, you know, the point of the criminal justice system should be to reduce the amount of crime we have, to reduce the number of victims, particularly of physical crimes like sexual violence and physical violence and domestic violence, etc. And to make society as a whole a safer place and a better place. Now, if you set those as your milestones of success, then you would do nothing that we're currently doing in our criminalism. justices and you would completely rip up the rule book and you start again and you would do the
持续更长时间，犯罪程度更严重。但如果你对那个计划感到满意，坚持不断延长刑期和加重监狱条件，那随你便。对我来说，刑事司法系统的意义应该是减少我们拥有的犯罪数量，减少受害者人数，特别是性暴力、身体暴力和家庭暴力等身体犯罪的受害者。并使整个社会成为一个更安全、更好的地方。现在，如果你把这些作为成功的里程碑，那么你将不会做我们目前在刑事司法中所做的任何事情，你会彻底撕毁规则手册，重新开始，你会做
sorts of things that I wrote about injustice on trial. Yeah and one of your ideas injustice on trial was you know allow people to continue to do their jobs you know and then maybe go home to prison in the evening but still be able to contribute or just be I don't know just still be able to contribute to their families and you know so much of that then helps their self-esteem and And what we know about even very rudimentary measures of childhood adversity, such as the A-scale, you know, has one of your parents ever been in prison? And if we're saying yes to that, we're already giving this potentially unborn baby, you know, at least one point on their own adverse childhood experience rating, which will be with them for life. And yeah, I think it's so hard to
我在《正义在审判中》中写到的那些事情。是的，你在《正义在审判中》中的一个想法是，允许人们继续工作，然后晚上可能回到监狱，但仍然能够做出贡献，或者只是能够为他们的家庭做出贡献。这其中很大一部分有助于他们的自尊。我们所知道的关于童年逆境的初步衡量标准，例如ACE量表，你知道，“你的父母中是否有人曾经入狱？”如果我们对这个问题回答“是”，我们已经在给这个潜在的未出生婴儿，至少在他们的不良童年经历评分上加了一分，这将伴随他们一生。是的，我认为
get a job once you've been through the justice system and turned out the other side. And it was really interesting learning a bit more about Jamie Oliver's 15 program recently. I think until until very recently I thought it was just a TV thing, whereas actually he bankrolled a lot of that himself. You know, it's very, very expensive. But it's changed people's lives. And it's the same with the organisation, Change Please, you know, really trying to do something different to teach people skills and to have people be mentored by people to show them a different way. And I think why aren't we doing more of this? Well, we're not doing it for the simple reason
一旦你经历了司法系统并从另一端出来，就很难找到工作了。最近了解更多关于杰米·奥利弗（Jamie Oliver）的“15”项目真的很有趣。我想直到最近我才认为那只是一个电视节目，而实际上他自己资助了其中的大部分。你知道，这非常非常昂贵。但它改变了人们的生活。与“Change Please”组织一样，他们真的在尝试做一些不同的事情，教人们技能，并让人们接受导师指导，向他们展示一条不同的道路。我想，为什么我们不多做这些呢？嗯，我们不这样做，原因很简单，
that we are addicted to the use of punishments as the only weapon against any form of behaviour that transgresses social norms. So, you know, we, we, you know, and it's incredibly easy. If you think about it from a psychological point of view, the messaging around getting tough in inverted commas and cracking down in inverted commas once again.
那就是我们沉迷于使用惩罚作为对抗任何违背社会规范行为的唯一武器。所以，你知道，我们，你知道，这从心理学角度来看非常容易。关于“强硬”和“打击”的言论再次出现。
And all of these things, we're going to have a crackdown on, you know, whatever it might be, you know, street drug dealing. just drug dealing generally um uh all these kind of things we're going to have crackdown it sound great it sounds great on tv and it sounds great on you know and big rallies and political speeches and so forth it's and people love it because we we as a species we do we are can be quite basic and we do have some extraordinary basic instinct such as revenge and punishment they're very visceral and they're very kind of um you know they're easy to relate to it needs to get
所有这些事情，我们要对街头毒品交易、一般毒品交易等进行打击，所有这些事情，我们要进行打击。这听起来很棒，在电视上听起来很棒，在大型集会和政治演讲中听起来也很棒。人们喜欢它，因为我们作为一个物种，确实可以非常基础，我们确实有一些非凡的基本本能，例如复仇和惩罚。它们非常发自内心，非常容易产生共鸣。需要被
carried away with the problem is that they are part of our very you know you and your or listeners will be much more aware of the thing. But it's part of that very ancient kind of brain, as opposed to the brain that has the intellectual capacity to use creativity and compassion and pragmatism to solve problems as opposed to simply react with big sticks, you know, as if we're sort of cavemen and the only solution to any sort of incursion onto our land
冲昏头脑。问题是它们是我们非常……你知道，你和你的听众会更了解这一点。但这是那个非常古老的大脑的一部分，而不是那个拥有智力能力去利用创造力、同情心和实用主义来解决问题的大脑，而不是简单地用大棒做出反应，好像我们是穴居人，对我们土地的任何入侵的唯一解决方案
is to go and attack and burn down the other village. And that's the kind of mentality that still drives our criminal justices. And it doesn't drive all of our society. There are bits of it, particularly in the scientific community. and medical research and so forth where people are very much focused on doing good and using using human ingenuity to solve problem but in criminal justice we are stuck with a you know as i described in the book i you know i went back to myan civilizations from you know 10 000 years ago and and all of the civilization since you know almost every single society or civilization
就是去攻击并烧毁另一个村庄。这就是仍然驱动我们刑事司法的那种心态。它并没有驱动我们所有的社会。社会中有一些部分，特别是在科学界、医学研究等领域，人们非常专注于做好事，利用人类的聪明才智来解决问题。但在刑事司法中，我们被困在了一个……正如我在书中描述的那样，我回到了1万年前的玛雅文明，以及自那以后的所有文明，你知道，几乎每一个社会或文明
you've had over the last several thousand years has in terms of its The climate has always had fundamentally an approach which is aggressive, which is punitive, and which in my opinion is damaging to social cohesion, society and safety, public safety. But we do these things, partly because actually politicians really love to leverage those messaging at election times. And, you know, a very large number of people, you know, respond positively to them. Yeah, I mean, when we really boil it down, law is a complete social construction, right? It's a way of stopping people rioting in the streets and trying to get the masses to behave themselves.
在过去几千年中，在气候方面，其基本方法总是具有侵略性、惩罚性的，在我看来，这对社会凝聚力、社会和公共安全是有害的。但我们做这些事情，部分是因为政客们确实喜欢在选举时利用这些信息。而且，有很大一部分人对这些信息做出了积极的回应。是的，我的意思是，当我们真正归结起来时，法律完全是一种社会建构，对吧？这是一种阻止人们在街上暴乱并试图让大众守规矩的方法。
But it's, yeah, it is just a social construction. And, you know, different places over the countries around the world interpret it, slightly different to have their own laws. But I don't know, it's when you get all introspective and, you know, yeah, like just thinking about this, it's bonkers, right? like there has to be a way of, I guess, getting us to all stop killing each other. Well, you say that. You would hope so, wouldn't you, accept that, you know, the history of the human species is not exactly, which has been occupied by peaceful, you know, kind motives most
但这确实只是一种社会建构。而且，世界各地的不同地方对它的解释略有不同，有他们自己的法律。但我不知道，当你变得内省时，就像思考这个问题，这太疯狂了，对吧？一定有一种方法，我想，能让我们都停止互相残杀。嗯，你这么说。你会希望如此，不是吗？除非，你知道，人类物种的历史并不完全是被和平的、善良的动机所占据的，
of the time. And indeed, some reason, you know, because resources are finite and there's been a need over human history for people to battle for limited resource. And of course, that's the case, evolution has brought, you know, battle over resource is very much fundamental to the evolution of all species. So there's nothing fundamentally kind of wrong with that. The difficulty is because we've evolved to the point where we have this very, very high levels of intelligence compared to other animals and compared to, you know, other, our sort of ancestor species beforehand, you've still got the basic bits of the brain, but we've bolted on these clever bits on the top over a very short period of time because, you know, it is only really
大部分时间。事实上，某种原因，因为资源是有限的，人类历史上一直需要人们为有限的资源而战。当然，情况确实如此，进化带来了……为资源而战是所有物种进化的基础。所以这在根本上并没有什么错。困难在于，我们已经进化到拥有比其他动物和我们的祖先物种更高的智力水平，你仍然拥有大脑的基本部分，但我们在很短的时间内就在上面安装了这些聪明的部件，因为，你知道，这只是在
in the sort of history of life on earth you know the the modern human with our intellectual capability that you know it represents like just a tiny minute fraction of the entire history of life on earth and and life on the planet and and so we just haven't you know we we haven't caught up with ourselves that's my opinion we have we haven't we haven't caught up with the fact that you know if you live in an in a world of ever increasing numbers of people but you also have the technology to feed all those people, actually, and we do. We do have the technology to do it. The problem is that you still have people who are mostly drawn to arguments over emotion and culture and history and identity and the sorts of things that, you know,
地球生命史中，拥有我们智力能力的现代人类，只代表了地球生命史的一小部分。所以我们还没有赶上我们自己，这是我的观点。我们还没有赶上这样一个事实：如果你生活在一个人口不断增加的世界里，但你同时也拥有养活所有这些人的技术，实际上，我们确实有。我们确实有技术做到这一点。问题在于，你仍然有那些主要被关于情感、文化、历史和身份的争论所吸引的人，以及那些，你知道，
really are quite powerful and have been important, you know, incredibly important for our evolution, you know, the idea of community, albeit, of course, it would have been small communities up until relatively recent, up until the last 300 years, you know, communities were really quite small and now we suddenly have this huge world where everybody can speak to everybody all the time where you can travel anywhere all the time where there are bombs that can can bomb you from almost anywhere and we just haven't we haven't as a species in my opinion like you know used our talents to improve the planet we've you we have improved the planet in some ways but ultimately overall we have done more harm than good and and unless we grapple with that as a
确实非常强大，并且对我们的进化非常重要的事情。你知道，社区的概念，尽管当然，直到最近，直到过去300年，社区确实很小。而现在我们突然拥有了这个巨大的世界，每个人都可以随时与每个人交谈，你可以随时去任何地方，有炸弹可以从几乎任何地方轰炸你。我们作为一个物种，在我看来，还没有利用我们的才能来改善这个星球。我们在某些方面改善了星球，但最终总体上，我们弊大于利。除非我们作为一个
reality either as an you know an environmental reality or as a social reality we're never going to, we're never going to make forward progress in my opinion. Amazing. Thank you. That was really interesting. I know you spoke in the book about a particular country that says that anyone under the age of 18 cannot be, you know, culpable for anything illegal, which is kind of quite radical, certainly from a UK justice perspective, because you talk us through that, Chris. Yeah, so it's Luxembourg, a small country which within its constitution, its constitutional framework says that no child under 18 shall ever be convicted of a crime. So what they've done is they've aligned the age of majority where you can vote and you're a full sort of adult and participant in society. They've aligned that age with the age of criminal responsibility, which in the UK is a complete mismatch because the age of criminal responsibility is only 10 years of age.
现实来处理这个问题，无论是环境现实还是社会现实，在我看来，我们永远不会取得进步。太棒了。谢谢。这真的很有趣。我知道你在书中谈到了一个特定的国家，它说任何18岁以下的人都不能对任何非法行为负责，这在某种程度上是相当激进的，当然从英国司法的角度来看是这样。克里斯，你能给我们讲讲吗？是的，那是卢森堡，一个在其宪法框架内规定“任何18岁以下的儿童都不得被判犯罪”的小国。所以他们所做的是，他们将成年年龄（你可以投票并成为社会的完全参与者）与刑事责任年龄保持一致，而在英国，这是一个完全的不匹配，因为刑事责任年龄只有10岁。
Whereas, of course, the age of the majority is the same as Luxembourg, 18. And so you have this, you know, in Luxembourg, what they've done is that, of course, occasionally, and it is very occasionally, children commit acts of real violence and real harm. And it's incredibly rare. I think, you know, if you watch the media coverage in the UK, you think that children are out killing each other all the time. It's a very, very, very small number, in fact. And the only reason why there's so much media coverage of when a child kills someone or what have you is because it's so rare. You know, if it wasn't rare, you know, it wouldn't make the news so much. So what they've done in Luxembourg, they said, okay, when those very rare events happen and a child is genuinely dangerous, may have harmed someone and maybe a danger, what we do is we focus the resources of the state on the child welfare, and of course, public protection is important.
当然，卢森堡的成年年龄和我们一样，都是18岁。在卢森堡，他们所做的是，当然，偶尔——而且是非常偶尔——会有儿童犯下真正的暴力和造成真正伤害的行为。这种情况极其罕见。我认为，如果你看英国的媒体报道，你会觉得孩子们整天都在互相残杀。事实上，这只是极少数情况。媒体之所以会对儿童杀人等事件进行大量报道，唯一的原因就是它太罕见了。你知道，如果这不罕见，它就不会上那么多新闻了。所以卢森堡的做法是，他们说，好吧，当那些非常罕见的事件发生，且一个孩子确实具有危险性，可能伤害了他人并构成威胁时，我们所做的是将国家资源集中在儿童福利上，当然，公共安全也很重要。
So the way that they do it is that they have, you know, they have to have secure environments for those children, those small number of children who are genuinely dangerous. And those secure environments are schools and their entire ethos and their entire purpose is to educate. the child and to address any psychological harms or other welfare issues that the child has had so that when they become adults they in the vast majority of cases go out into society and never commit a crime ever again and that's the statistical reality of that system whereas our system is to criminalise children as young as 10 11 12 years of age imprison them sometimes at the age of 13 or 14 15 in young offenders institutions which are just prisons and we put in 14 15 year old kids in prison. Now that to me in a nutshell tells you why our system is so broken
他们采取的方式是，为那些真正危险的少数儿童提供安全的环境。这些安全环境就是学校，它们的全部宗旨和目的就是教育孩子，并解决孩子所遭受的任何心理创伤或其他福利问题，这样当他们成年后，绝大多数人都能回归社会，再也不会犯罪，这就是该制度的统计学现实。而我们的制度则是将年仅10岁、11岁、12岁的儿童刑事定罪，有时在13、14、15岁时就将他们关进青少年罪犯管教所，那其实就是监狱，我们把14、15岁的孩子关进监狱。对我来说，这简而言之说明了为什么我们的制度如此破碎。
because I've been into young append institutions many many times. I know you have and and you know those places are soul destroying when you think that there are children being housed in cells with bars and all of the other trappings of a prison it to me that's a form of madness and not only madness but cruelty because the end result is you you double down on the damage that that young person has had in their early life and you absolutely guarantee that that young person is likely to commit violent and other crimes again in later life in part in an understandable direct reaction to the trauma that they've been facing and have faced including at the hands of the state and and that's why in my view and i wrote about it in the book
因为我多次去过青少年管教所。我知道你去过，而且你知道那些地方是摧毁灵魂的。当你想到有孩子被关在有铁栏杆的牢房里，还有监狱的所有其他配套设施时，对我来说，这是一种疯狂，不仅是疯狂，更是残忍。因为最终的结果是你加剧了那个年轻人早年所受的伤害，你绝对保证了那个年轻人很可能在以后的生活中再次犯下暴力和其他罪行，这在一定程度上是对他们所面临的创伤的一种可以理解的直接反应，包括来自国家层面的伤害，这就是为什么我认为，我在书中也写到了这一点。
children you know i have lots of children and and they i do not believe for example that my 11-year-old son is capable of the kinds of level of kind of depravity or what have you, or any 11-year-old, in fact, that he's required to say in a court of law that you're guilty of murder and you should be sent to prison for years and years and years. Anyone who ever spent any time with any young children knows that they are so far from that level of insight and development and even capacity for that level of cruelty. They may do cruel acts. They may do things that are violent, But they have no real processing power when it comes to what's going on there or why they're doing it. And the vast majority of the time, it is a direct result of someone doing something terrible to them, usually an adult.
孩子们，你知道，我有很多孩子，我不相信我的11岁儿子有能力做出那种程度的堕落行为，或者任何11岁的孩子有这种能力，事实上，他被要求在法庭上承认谋杀罪，并被判处多年监禁。任何与幼儿相处过的人都知道，他们离那种洞察力、发展水平，甚至那种程度的残忍能力还差得很远。他们可能会做出残忍的行为。他们可能会做暴力的事情，但当涉及到事情的本质或他们为什么要这样做时，他们没有真正的处理能力。绝大多数情况下，这是某人对他们做了可怕事情的直接结果，通常是成年人。
And so, in my opinion, if you decriminalise children, as they do in Luxembourg on their welfare, as a constitutional principle, then what you will have coming out the other side into adulthood will, in the great majority of cases, not be those people who make up the adult prison population in our current system. At the moment, all that our youth justice system does is feed the adult criminal justice system. It doesn't reduce crime. It doesn't make our country a safer place. So it fails by my fundamental measures of success in criminal justice. Yeah. And also what I know as a psychologist is that our human brains aren't actually fully matured until we've got our full frontal lobe capacity, which is around 25. I was much less of a dick at 25 than I was at 18. You know, I used to think it was probably a good idea to get my friends to put me in a shopping trolley and wheel me down the hill when I was 18.
所以，在我看来，如果你像卢森堡那样，将儿童非刑事化，将其作为宪法原则，那么你最终得到的成年人，在绝大多数情况下，将不会是我们当前制度下成年监狱人口的组成部分。目前，我们的青少年司法系统所做的只是为成人刑事司法系统输送人员。它不能减少犯罪。它没有让我们的国家变得更安全。所以，按照我衡量刑事司法成功的根本标准，它是失败的。是的。而且作为一名心理学家，我知道人类的大脑实际上并没有完全成熟，直到我们拥有完整的前额叶皮层功能，那大约是在25岁左右。我在25岁时比18岁时要稳重得多。你知道，我18岁时曾认为让朋友把我放在购物车里推下山是个好主意。
I was not doing that when I was 25, Chris. So the idea that you would hold someone accountable for their actions at 10 or 12, like it's just, yeah, it's broken. It doesn't make sense. Well, it doesn't make sense from just just common sense. Never mind, never mind the sort of the, you know, the psychological appreciation of development and how human development takes a long time. and particularly for young men, that development process does run right into the mid-20s and even into the, in beyond. And so if you, once you begin to understand that, then you start to play the man instead
我25岁时可没干过那种事，克里斯。所以，你认为一个10岁或12岁的孩子要为自己的行为负责，这简直是……是的，这制度坏透了。这说不通。好吧，仅从常识来看，这都说不通。更不用说对人类发展的心理学理解，以及人类发展需要很长时间这一事实了。特别是对于年轻男性来说，这个发展过程确实会一直持续到20多岁，甚至更久。所以，一旦你开始理解这一点，你就会开始关注“人”而不是“球”，换句话说，你实际上会说，好吧，我们面对的是谁？是谁在做这些事，他们为什么要这样做？特别是当你把这种框架应用到18岁以下的儿童身上时，任何有同情心和理性的人几乎不可避免的反应都是：我们需要关注最初的创伤，即导致这种行为的大部分心理创伤，但我们也需要考虑什么能真正改变这种行为的实际情况，而有一件事是肯定会让情况变得更糟的，那就是把他们送进儿童监狱。所以，停止这样做。就这么简单。是的，我经常被问到。
of the ball, so to speak, you actually say, okay, who are we dealing with? Who are doing these things and why are they doing them? Particularly when you're applying that kind of framework to children under 18, then the almost inevitable response of anyone who's compassionate and rational is we need to focus on the the original trauma, so the psychological kind of trauma that underlies much of this behaviour, but we also need to think about the practical reality of what's going to hopefully change the course of some of that behaviour and that one thing that is guaranteed to make it worse is sending them to a child prison. And so stop doing that. It's as simple as that. Yeah, I'm often asked
在媒体上发言，试图帮助人们理解高调案件发生时的困难立场。当然，公众对此有很大的兴趣，因为媒体对此进行了广泛报道。你知道吗，在卢森堡，如果发生了涉及儿童的高调或非常严重的事件，媒体还会报道吗，还是完全不报道？不，因为他们有匿名保护。我的意思是，我们这里当然在一定程度上也有匿名保护，但法官经常会因为案件特别令人震惊而取消这种保护。他们说，好吧，我们可以披露这些14、15岁的人是谁，他们的名字可以告诉所有人。这创造了一辈子都需要保护他们、给他们新身份以及所有其他随之而来的麻烦。
in the media to talk, to try and help people understand difficult positions when there has been high-profile cases. And of course, there's a great public interest in that because it's been so widely reported in the media. Do you know, in Luxembourg, if there is a high-profile or very serious things happened with a child, is that still reported in the media or not at all? No, because they have anonymity. I mean, we, of course, have anonymity here to a degree, but often the judge will waive that because the case is particularly shocking. And they say, okay, well, we can disclose who these 14 and 15-year-olds are and their names could be told to everybody. create a lifetime of needing to keep them, give them new identities and all the other stuff
他们没有。他们完全被禁止以任何形式报道任何涉及儿童的事情。而且作为一种安全措施，他们的宪法立场是默认任何儿童都不可能犯下罪行。所有儿童都有权获得国家的关注，即他们的福利和福祉。当然，他们必须为那极少数人增加公共保护，如果你带走一个孩子，而不是因为他们为帮派运毒而惩罚他们，而他们才11或12岁，
that goes with that. No, they don't. They are completely prevented from any form of reporting of anything that involves a child. And as a safe, their constitutional position is that the default position is no child can ever be guilty of a crime. And all children are entitled to have the focus of the state, their welfare and their well-being. And of course, they have to add on the protection of the public for that tiny number, if you take a child, instead of punishing them because they were running drugs for a gang and they were only 11 or 12,
他们被抓到带着一些毒品或其他什么东西，他停下来会说，好吧，这是一种刑事司法干预，我们现在需要逮捕他们，我们现在需要通过警察局处理他们，你会对自己说，一个12岁的孩子带着一袋垃圾在跑来跑去是在干什么？所以为什么会发生这种情况？
they got caught with some gear or whatever it was, he stops to say, okay, this is a criminal justice intervention, we now need to arrest them, we now need to process them through a police station, and you say to yourself, what on earth is a 12 year old doing running around with bags of crap? So why is that happening?
然后你为了他们的福利进行干预，而不是因为他们所做的任何事情而惩罚他们，但你会问自己，他们是怎么走到这一步的，我们如何把他们从那种环境中拉出来，确保他们能过上基本需求得到满足的生活，让他们能接受某种教育，让他们在心理和其他福祉方面的因素得到解决？当你开始从刑事司法的完全另一端来看待这个问题时，你得到的结果是非常非凡的，比我们的系统成功得多，而且比无疑是世界上最破碎的美国系统要成功得多。
And you intervene then for their welfare, not to punish them for whatever it is that they've been doing, but you ask yourselves, how did they get there, How do we take them out of that and make sure that they can get into a life where their basic needs are taking care of, where they can get some sort of education where their psychological and other well-being factors can be addressed? And when you start looking at it from the completely other end of the telescope from criminal justice, the outcomes that you get are quite extraordinary and so much more successful than our system and infinitely more successful than what is undoubtedly the most broken system in the world of the US.
是的，我认为我们还需要考虑羞耻感的影响，你知道，当全世界都在谈论你，因为他们在报纸上读到了关于你的报道，而我们面对的这些人可能在生活中已经经历过非常强烈的羞耻感。这真的很有破坏性，对我们的大脑真的很有破坏性。是的，我认为让我感到非常震惊的一件事是，几年前我为BBC拍摄时，我们在苏格兰的一家青少年罪犯管教所拍摄。我与监狱长谈过。我为节目采访了监狱长。她在监狱系统工作了很多很多年。她是苏格兰最大的青少年罪犯管教所的监狱长。我想那里关押了1200名年轻人。所以是一个很大的地方。她说，看，我这里的这些年轻人，
Yeah, and I think we also need to think about the impact of shame, you know, when the whole world is talking about you because they've read it in the newspaper, and we're already dealing with people that have probably had a very high shame experience in their life. It's really damaging, really damaging to our brains. Yeah, I think one of the things that really shocked me was when I was filming for the BBC a few years back, we filmed at a young offender's institution up in Scotland. And I spoke to the governor. I interviewed the governor for the programme. And she'd been in the prison service for many, many years. And she was the governor of the largest young offender's institution in Scotland. I think it had 1,200 young people in custody there. So a very big sort of place. And she said, look, these young people I have in here,
他们过去称他们为年轻人，他们不称他们为囚犯。他们至少试图使用一种在我看来稍微合理一点的语言。但她说，看，我这里的年轻人，在他们14或15岁来到这里之前，已经目睹了五起非自然死亡。比如有人死于过量用药、暴力或其他什么原因。但你能想象吗，14或15岁之前就经历了五次？我的意思是，我们大多数人从未经历过这样的事情。如果我们活到一千岁，我们也不会亲眼看到非自然死亡。
and they used to call them young, they didn't call them inmates. They at least tried to use sort of language that was a slightly more kind of reasonable, I suppose, in my view. But she said, look, I have young people in here who have witnessed by the age of 14 or 15 when they come in here. they've witnessed five unnatural deaths in front of them. So people dying of an overdose or violence or whatever it might be. But can you imagine that five by the age of 14 or 15? I mean, most of us have never experienced anything like that. If you live to a thousand, we'd never see an unnatural death right in front of us.
然而，这些年轻人经历了那种彻底的、难以想象的创伤，比如看着自己的父母之一死于过量用药或入狱，正如你所说。或者有时两者都有。你知道，她说这里有很多人，父母双方都在监狱里。孩子也在监狱里。这就像，好吧，等等。在某个时刻，你会对自己说，他们不是在责怪这些孩子做了一些完全超出他们控制范围的事情吗？
And yet these young people had experienced that utter, like the trauma that is unimaginable of seeing one of your parents die of an overdose or go to prison, as you say. Or sometimes both. You know, she said there's many people in here, both parents are in prison. And the kids in prison too. And he's just like, well, hold on. Like at some point, are you going to say to yourself, they're not blaming these kids for stuff that's completely out of their hands?
而且，这也是代际相传的。所以他们的父母也经历过同样的失调的刑事司法系统，这使他们无法就业，使他们陷入犯罪或其他形式的非法行为。而且，你知道，显而易见的是，一切都会向下传递。好的事情会代代相传，坏的事情也会代代相传，你必须停下来，你知道，这听起来真的很俗气，但作为一个社会，你必须拥抱孩子们。如果你不作为一个
And also, which is generational. So their parents who have been through the same dysfunctional criminal justice system, which has left them unemployable, which has left them in the vaulting crime or other forms of illegal behavior of some sort. And, you know, it is so obvious that everything, thing trickles down to summit. Good things trickle down generations and bad things trickle down generations and you just have to stop to it and put you know you know it sounds sort of really cheesy but you have to put your arms around children as a society if you don't as a
社会去拥抱那些最受伤害和最脆弱的儿童，那么社会的意义何在？如果你以残忍的方式对待那些受苦最深的孩子，这在什么意义上是一个社会？这正是我们正在做的，我认为这太可怕了，但我没有看到任何积极的公共政策迹象来解决这个问题。不，没有人谈论它，对吧？就像，我认为我们应该谈论，这也是我为什么想让你参加这个播客的另一个原因。在结束之前，另一个非常有趣的话题是，我们难道不应该把所有毒品合法化吗？你知道，你在书中提到了这一点。而且，在纸面上，你会觉得，嗯，不，当然不是。自从这本书出版以来，我想
society put your arms around the most damage of vulnerable children then what's the point of a society what in what way is it a society if you treat with cruelty those children who have suffered the most and that's exactly what we're doing and I think it's just horrendous but I see no sign whatsoever at all of anything positive in terms of public policy to address it. No, no one's talking about it, are they? Like, and I think we should be, which is another reason why I wanted you on this podcast. Another really interesting thing to talk about just before we finish is the idea, should we not just legalise all drugs? You know, you put that in your book. And, you know, on paper, you're like, well, no, of course not. Since the book was published, I think
纽约已经让大麻合法化了，我没说错吧？哦，不仅仅是纽约。我的意思是美国一半的州。好吧。苏格兰开设了消费室，我知道在书中你提到，实际上有些国家已经超越了这一点，实际上确实提供了医用级海洛因，例如。你能给我们谈谈这一切吗，请？好的，我会的。所以毒品，毒品在我的书中、在我对刑事司法的思考中占据如此重要地位的原因是，它在刑事司法
New York has made cannabis legal, am I right in saying that? Oh, not just New York. I mean, half the states of the US. Okay. Scotland has opened up consumption rooms, and I know in the book you speak about, actually some countries have gone beyond that and actually do issue medical grade heroin, for example. Could you talk to us a little bit about all that, please? Yeah, I will. So drugs is, the reason drugs play such a big part in my book, of my thinking about criminal justice is because it plays such a big part in the criminal justice
系统中占据了如此大的比重。所以毒品犯罪和毒品违法行为代表了直接的毒品犯罪，比如毒品交易、毒品持有和贩运等，代表了刑事司法中很大很大的一部分。这在各种不同类型的情况下都是如此，显然从低级别的街头毒贩到大规模的国际吨级毒品进口。所以这是刑事司法的一部分，而刑事司法的另一部分，当然是所有那些必须支付巨额费用购买毒品的成瘾者。我认为大多数人可能没有意识到，毒品其实很便宜。如果你去阿富汗，你可以用几千块钱买一公斤海洛因。当它经过六个不同的物流阶段运送到英国的用户手中时，那一公斤海洛因就变成了10万英镑。
system. So drug crimes and drug offences represent a direct drug crimes like drug dealing and drug possession and trafficking, etc. represent a big, big chunk of criminal justice. And that's sort of across a wide range of different types of situations, obviously from sort of low level, street level dealers up to vast international importations of tons of drugs at a time. But so that's sort of one chunk of criminal justice and the other chunk of criminal justice, of course, is all of those people who are addicted who have to pay for the drugs at vast expense. And I think what most people probably don't realize is that drugs are really cheap. If you were to go to Afghanistan, you could buy a kilo of heroin for a couple of grand. By the time it's being transported through six different stages of logistics to get to a user in the UK, that's saying kilo of heroin is 100 grand.
它的价值翻了50倍，而价值翻了50倍并不是因为海洛因生产成本高，因为如果那样的话，在阿富汗一公斤纯海洛因就不会只卖两千块钱，而是因为以非法方式运输的成本非常高。所以后果就是，你的毒品用户在芝加哥、伦敦、伯明翰或任何地方，在那些所有这些毒品使用率很高的国家，那些较富裕的国家，用户在街头购买的成本是每周几百英镑。现在，谁有每周几百英镑？好吧，没有人，不是那种容易对快克、海洛因或香料上瘾的人。
it's got up 50-fold in value and it's got up 50-fold in value not because heroin's expensive to make because if it was it wouldn't cost two grams for a kilo of pure heroin in Afghanistan but because it's very expensive to transport in an illegal way and so the consequences that your drug users are in Chicago or London or Birmingham or wherever in a sort of in the countries where that have a high use rates of all of these drugs the the wealthier countries the cost on the street of a to a user is hundreds of pounds or week now who Who's got hundreds of pounds a week? Well, nobody, not the sort of people that tend to become addicted to crack or heroin or spice.
那么这些人如何负担得起每周几百英镑呢？答案是他们必须犯罪来获取钱财。所以你有一个系统，你为那些其实并不昂贵、价值也不高的毒品创造了一个人为的市场。突然间，因为它们的成瘾性、它们的成瘾特性，以及由于警察干预等原因导致供应链的巨大损耗率，它们变得昂贵了。你最终会问自己这个问题：毒品有什么问题吗？答案是：不，当然没有。事实上，证据是，你知道，
And so how do those people afford hundreds of pounds a week? The answer is they have to commit crime to get it. And so you have a system where you create an artificial market for drugs that aren't really that expensive and aren't worth very much. And suddenly they are because of their addictive qualities and their addictive properties and because of the huge kind of attrition rate through the supply chain of police intervention, etc. You end up with a situation where you could ask yourself this, is there anything wrong with drugs? And the answer is no, of course there isn't. And in fact, the evidence is, you know,
我在书中写道，毒品和精神活性物质，天然的精神活性物质，是人类进化中非常重要的一部分。它们带来了巨大的进步，因为我们与这些精神活性物质共同进化。我们与它们共同进化的原因，是因为它们有助于那些想象力的飞跃，这些科学的飞跃和人类创造力的飞跃，将我们带到了我们自身进化的另一个阶段。所以毒品在人类进化中一直扮演着某种角色。当你有一个整个行业，完全专注于让人们
I wrote about in the book, is that drugs and psychotropic substances, natural psychotropic substances, were a huge part of human evolution. They led to big advances because we co-evolved with these psychotropic substances. And the reason we co-evolved with them, because they help those leaps of imagination, these leaps of kind of science and these leaps of human ingenuity, which took us to another stage of our own evolution. And so drugs have always played a part in human evolution. When you have a sort of an entire industry, which is focused entirely on getting people
为了利润而对毒品上瘾，那么你最终会得到我们现在的情况，即毒品本身往往是不安全的，因为没有人真正知道里面有什么。它们可能被掺杂了各种东西。它们可能太弱，也可能太强。我们可能有，你知道，掺假物，各种毒药，等等，等等。
addicted to drugs for profit, then you end up with the situation we have, which is the drugs themselves can often be unsafe to take because no one really knows what's in them. They could be chopped together with all sorts. They could either be too weak, too strong. We could have, you know, adulterants, all sorts of poisons, et cetera, et cetera.
所以我们有所有这些问题。所以如果你摆脱了所有这些噪音，瑞士就做了完全相同的事情，我在书中写到了。那么瑞士做了什么？他们有数百人躺在火车站，手臂上插着针头，还有公园和游乐场。80年代瑞士爆发了海洛因流行病。现在，你在那里做什么？
So we have all of that. So if you get rid of all that noise and Switzerland did exactly that, and I wrote about it in the book. So what they did in Switzerland? They had hundreds of people lying around in railway stations with needles sticking out of their arm and parks and playgrounds. And there was a heroin epidemic in the 80s in Switzerland. Now, what do you do there?
好吧，我们在西方或者我们在英国或美国所做的是，我们只是增加了毒品交易的刑期。我们判处越来越长的刑期。以至于现在在英国，毒品贩运的刑期达到了30年。在美国，人们因为供应大麻被判处终身监禁且不得假释，甚至三振出局法案。他们必须为此在监狱里待上60年。所以瑞士的做法是，他们说，好吧，让我们换个角度看。所有这些海洛因的真正问题是什么？
Okay, what we do in the West or what we do in the UK or in America, is we just increase the sentences for drug dealing. And we get bigger and bigger sentences. to the point that people now in the UK are getting sentences of 30 years for drug trafficking. And in the US, people are getting life without parole, strikes as supplying cannabis. And they have to be in prison for 60 years for that. So what they've done in Switzerland was they said, OK, let's look at it a slightly different way. What is what is the real problem with all this heroin?
真正的问题是街上那些手臂上插着针头的人，人们在日内瓦和苏黎世等地的街头过量用药而死。这就是问题所在。问题不在于海洛因作为一种物质，问题在于人们正在死去。那么你如何避免死亡，你如何避免黑帮供应链以及地盘争夺战等等？答案是政府免费提供海洛因。所以，好吧，我们不能那样做。人们说，这肯定是不对的。但为什么不对呢？所以，我参观了日内瓦的海洛因辅助治疗项目。他们所做的，确实，有海洛因成瘾的人可以去海洛因辅助治疗项目，
And the real problem is it's the people on the streets with the needles that connect their arm, people overdosing and dying on the streets of Geneva and Zurich, etc. That's the problem. The problem isn't heroin as a substance. the problem is people are dying. So how do you avoid the death and how do you avoid the gangland supply chains and the and the turf wars, etc? And the answer is the government gives the heroin way for free. And so, and okay, well, we can't do that. Surely that's wrong, people say. But why is it wrong? So, so I visited the heroin assisted treatment programs in, in Geneva. And what they do, they literally, people who have a heroin addiction can go to the heroin assisted treatment program
他们将获得定制剂量的医药级海洛因，他们可以在监督条件下服用，如果有护士在场，如果有人过量用药或出现问题，他们可以立即获得医疗援助。这些人中的大多数人不会犯任何罪，而且它花费国家的成本只是我们在英国处理海洛因成瘾者所花费成本的一小部分，因为那些人被刑事定罪，成为了整个刑事司法行业的一部分，逮捕、高调审判和长期监禁，所有这些东西。但瑞士人悄悄做的事情，并不是一个以激进左翼政策闻名的国家，绝不是。他们在瑞士悄悄做的是几乎根除了街头的过量用药，特别是在日内瓦，这是我访问的城市。
and they will be given a bespoke dosage of pharmaceutical grade heroin which they can take under supervised conditions with nurses available if someone does overdose or something goes wrong they have medical assistance immediately to hand the majority of those people don't commit any crimes and it costs the state a tiny fraction of what it costs us in the UK to deal with people with heroin addiction because those people have been criminalised and a part of the whole you know industry of criminal justice the arrests and the high profile trials and the going to prison for for a long time, all of that stuff. But what they've done quietly in Switzerland, not a country renowned for its radical left-wing policies by any mean. What they've quietly done in Switzerland is almost eradicated overdose on the streets of Geneva, in particular, which is the city that I visited.
所以他们从每年数百起过量用药，变成了几乎零过量死亡。然后他们还几乎消除了所有与毒品相关的犯罪，那些街头犯罪，那些交易，或者入室盗窃和抢劫以及用来买毒品的东西。几乎全部消失了。对我来说，这说明这不仅仅是关于合法化，
So they went from having hundreds of overdoses a year, so almost zero deaths by overdose a year. And then they also got rid of almost all of the drug-related crime, that street crimes, that's dealing, or burned, burglaries and robberies and stuff that's used to buy drugs. And it's almost all gone. And that, to me, tells you that it's not just about legalisation,
因为合法化本身不起作用，因为你仍然有毒品帮派供应一切。这真的不起作用，因为那些帮派仍然会暴力。他们仍然会争夺地盘，他们仍然会做所有其他损害我们社会的事情。但如果作为一个社会，你决定许可毒品供应，这样人们可以获得，当然是成年人可以获得毒品，但他们知道里面有什么。就像他们知道一瓶威士忌里有什么一样，或者我并不是说酒精是一件伟大的
because legalisation on its own doesn't work because you still have drug gangs supplying everything. And that doesn't really work because those gangs are still going to be violent. They're still going to compete for turf and they're still going to do all the other sort of the things that damage our society. But if as a society, you decide to license drug supply so that people can get adults, of course, can get drugs, but they know what's in them. just as they know what's in a bottle of whiskey, or I'm not suggesting that alcohol is a great
事情。它造成了很大的伤害。但事实是，没有人会拿一罐啤酒，而它比他们想象的强八倍。他们因为一次喝了太多酒精而猝死，却不知道罐子里有什么。至少在一个合法化和许可的系统中，人们知道他们在服用什么。所以我在研究这本书时遇到的最大悲剧是年轻人的死亡，特别是未成年儿童，他们因为服用毒品而死，而他们根本不知道自己在服用什么，结果发现他们服用的是如此强烈的东西，足以杀死，你知道，10匹马，更不用说一个15岁的女孩了，这是我在书中写到的故事之一，你知道，我们有一个年轻
thing. It does very big harms. But the fact is that nobody is taking a can of beer and it's eight times stronger than they think it is. And they drop debt because they had so much alcohol in one go and they didn't know what was in the can. At least in a legalized and licensed system, people know what they're taking. And so the biggest tragedy is that I've ever come across in my sort of research with a book were the deaths of young people, particularly underage children, them from taking drugs that they had no idea what they were taking and it turned out that they were taking something so strong it would have killed you know 10 horses never mind a 15 year old girl which is one of the stories I wrote about in the book you know where we had a young
女孩，她的母亲曾警告过她关于毒品的事情，以及它们如何，你知道，它们可以在里面放东西，它们可以使用掺假物，所以她曾对她的朋友说，我们需要，你知道，我们需要确保，因为如果是纯的，那么我们就会没事的。问题是他们确实得到了，他们得到了92%纯度的MDMA，她在几个小时内就死了，因为它太强了。在一个合法的许可市场中，这种情况永远不会发生，因为即使年轻人拿到了毒品，他们至少会知道它们是什么，他们至少会知道，因为它们装在包装里，上面告诉你里面有什么，就像年轻人拿到啤酒、葡萄酒、伏特加或任何东西时，他们知道自己在喝什么。对我来说，这至关重要，就像移除整个刑事
girl whose mother had cautioned her about drugs and how you know they can they can put stuff in them they can like they can use adulterance so she'd said to her friends we need to get the like we need to make sure because if it's pure that like then we're going to be okay problem is they did they got 92% pure MDMA and she died within a couple of hours because it was so strong in a legal license market that would never happen because even if young people got hold of drugs they'd at least know what they were they'd at least know because they come in a packet and they tell you what's in them just as when young people get hold of beer or wine or vodka or whatever they know what they're taking and that to me is critical as is removing the entire criminal
基础设施一样，整个毒品网络、帮派、供应链，你摆脱了所有这些，因为你可以去许可的药房购买摇头丸、大麻、可卡因或海洛因，尽管那将通过某种医疗辅助项目。如果你移除了周围所有的刑事基础设施，你最终会得到一个情况，即毒品的大部分危害，也就是，你知道，长期成瘾、缺乏医疗保健、缺乏资源等，然后最终是犯罪的旋转门，大部分都消失了，你最终得到的是相对少数的长期成瘾者，由国家以相对较低的成本提供服务，并且可以过上守法的生活。对于大多数
infrastructure the whole drug networks the gangs the supply chains you get rid of all of that because you can go to a license dispensary and get ecstasy or cannabis or cocaine or heroin for that matter, although that would be through a sort of medical-assisted program. If you remove all of the criminal infrastructure around it, you end up with a situation where most of the harms of drugs, which are, you know, a long-term addiction, lack of access to healthcare, lack of access to resource, et cetera, and then ultimately revolving door of criminality, most of that goes away and you end up with a relatively small number of long-term addicts who are serviced by the state at relatively low cost and who can live a law-abiding life for most of the
去瑞士那些诊所的人来说，他们去上大学或去工作，他们只是说我在候诊室，他们看起来不像英国的毒品成瘾者。他们看起来像我们其他人。只是他们对海洛因有心理上的长期生理心理成瘾，如果他们得到足够的海洛因，他们就没事了，然后他们可以过自己的生活，其中一些人，事实上随着时间的推移，人们会自然地戒掉这些毒品，尽管重点不是他们被告知必须戒掉毒品，他们被告知你可以服用毒品，但你知道，如果你不想再服用，我们会在那个过程中支持你，但如果你想服用一辈子，
people who go to those clinics in switzerland they go to college or they go to work and they just say i was in the waiting room they don't look like drug addicts look like in england they look like the rest of us it's just that they have a psychological long-term physical psychological addiction to mostly heroin and if they get enough heroin they're fine and and then they can live their life and some of them most of in fact over a time people come off those drugs naturally although that's not the point that they're not being told you have to come off drugs they're being told you can have the drugs but you know there's access to if you if you don't want to take them anymore this we're going to support you through that but if you want to take them for the rest of
我们也会支持你，因为最终你没有伤害任何人，你知道，你可能在伤害自己，但如果你没有伤害任何人，如果我们给你提供维持剂量的海洛因，以确保你可以在不犯罪、不去找街头毒贩或做任何那些事情的情况下正常生活，那么你最终会得到一个更安全得多的城市。不仅对用户来说更安全，对他们来说更安全，这对我来说很重要，可能对大多数人来说不重要，但对其他人来说更安全，因为那些犯罪层级中的许多已经消失了。所以当你看到什么真正能减少毒品危害时，你意识到最大的危害来自禁令本身，正如他们在100年前的美国发现的那样，当然，当
life we'll support you through that too because ultimately you're not doing anyone any harm you know you may be harming yourself but you're not harming anyone else if we're giving you a maintenance dose of heroin to make sure you can function without him to commit crimes or go to dealers on the streets or any of that stuff and you end up as i say with a much much safer city not only for the users safer for them which to me is important might not be to most people but safer for everybody else because so many of those layers of criminality have gone so when you when you see what actually works to reduce the harms of drugs you realize that the biggest harms come from prohibition itself as they found out in the US of course a hundred years ago when
他们尝试酒精禁令时，灾难性的错误导致了犯罪的巨大爆发，直到今天，100年前在禁令期间建立的有组织犯罪基础设施仍然存在，它在供应海洛因，它在供应冰毒，它在供应所有其他毒品。所以他们在各州所做的是在修补大麻合法化，那是，那是，那是，那是你能做的最低水平。对我来说，许可和合法化那些造成最直接危害的毒品要重要得多，也就是海洛因、快克，在美国是冰毒。
they when they experimented with prohibition of alcohol catastrophic mistake led to a huge explode crime which to this day the infrastructure of organized crime established a hundred years ago during prohibition still there it's supplying heroin and it's supplying it's supplying meth and it's supplying all the other drugs so what they're doing in the states is tinkering with legalization of cannabis that's the that's the that's the That's the lowest level that you could possibly do. And for me, it's far more important to licence and legalise those drugs that cause the most direct harm, which is heroin crack and in the US mess.
这太有趣了。我喜欢这个播客能让人们在职业生涯的早期就接触到这些，他们可能仍然有那种动力、好奇心和能力，有一天能把这些东西向前推进。与成瘾者一起工作非常重要，你知道，那个群体是心理资源服务最少的群体之一，而关于成瘾的大部分资源都集中在禁欲和试图让人们戒毒（用引号表示）上。如果你把这作为你的使命，你就会失败，因为许多许多人会
It's so, so interesting. I love that this podcast will be landing on people earlier in their career as well that might still have that drive and that curiosity and the ability to kind of maybe take some of this stuff forwards one day as well. working with addicts is really important and you know that that that community is one of the least served by psychological resource and and much of that resource which is there in in respect of addiction is all focused on abstinence and trying to get people off drugs in inverted comms if you bake that your mission you're going to fail because that because many many people will
保持成瘾状态，无论是酒精还是被禁止的毒品，因为他们就是那样被塑造的，这可能是无法治愈的。但即使你不能治愈成瘾，你也可以治愈成瘾带来的危害，不仅是对他们，而且是对你，对我们其他人。如果你们中任何未来的或年轻的心理学家正在寻找职业，你可以选择成瘾领域的职业，这不会比其他职业差。而且我想你在书中说，实际上即使在监狱里，人们进去时没有毒品问题，但因为毒品检测制度，因为海洛因在系统中的停留时间显然较短，他们很可能会转向海洛因，出来时就成了海洛因成瘾者。
remain addicted whether it's alcohol or to drugs which are prohibited because they are they're wired that way and it can be incurable but what even if you can't cure the addiction you can cure the harms of the addiction not just for them but for the you but for the rest of us and if any of your sort of future or young psychologists are looking for a career you could do much worse than a career in addiction and i think you said in the book that actually even in prison people will go into prison with no drug problems but because of the drug testing regimes because heroin apparently lasts less time in the system, they might well switch to heroin and come out as heroin addicts.
那可不好。那是一个可怕的政策。所以当他们几年前在监狱中引入所谓的MDT或强制毒品检测时，在此之前，大麻还算相当普遍，当然那时你仍然可以在监狱里抽烟。他们现在完全禁止在监狱里抽烟了。但在那时，大麻在监狱里相当普遍，监狱方面也睁一只眼闭一只眼。
And that is not good. That was a scary policy. So when they introduced what's called MDT or mandatory drug testing in prisons some years ago, prior to that, cannabis had been fairly, and of course you could still smoke in prisons then. They banned smoking in prisons now altogether. But at that time, cannabis was fairly common in prisons, and the prisons kind of turned a bit of a blind eye.
因为大多数情况下它并没有造成太大的伤害，因为它阻止了人们变得暴力，如果他们能接触到大麻，人们比没有接触时更顺从，所以这是一种……我记得在2000年代，也就是20多年前，我处理过非常非常暴力的客户案件，他们谈论的是那些会在抢劫过程中朝你的头部开枪的人，极其暴力的人。其中一个审判是关于一个客户，我在书中写到过，他用手枪和AK-47射击了五个人，你知道，所以是一个非常暴力的人。当我们等待判决结果时，我去了
it because mostly didn't do that much harm like mostly it stopped people being violent and people were more compliant if they had access to cannabis than if they didn't so it was kind of an i remember doing cases with very very violent clients back in the sort of 2000s like 20 something years ago and and they were talking about people who were like who would shoot your you in the head um in the course of a robbery like extraordinary violent people and one of these trials was a client was been tried who i wrote about in the book for for shooting five people with a with a with a with a handgun and an AK 47 you know so very violent individual and as they were as we were waiting for the verdict to come back I went down to
法院的高安全牢房，到处都是大麻烟雾，整个地方都是。我对监狱官员说，你知道，这是……他们在开派对还是什么的？他说，听着，让他们想抽多少就抽多少吧，因为他们不会给我们惹任何麻烦，他们只是坐在那里笑，像……你知道，我知道我显然把它推向了极端，但这就是发生的事情，这没有造成任何问题。所以后来他们引入了强制毒品检测，认为这是一个好主意，因为我们现在可以让人们戒毒了。但问题是，大麻在系统中的停留时间长达六周左右，它在血液中的半衰期非常长，所以当然人们
the high security cells at the courts and there was wads of cannabis smoke everywhere the whole the whole place and I said to the prison officers you know this is they having a party or something he said listen with this not let them smoke as much as they want because they don't cause us any trouble they're just sitting there and a laugh like like singing and you know like like which I know obviously I'm taking that to an extreme but but but that's what happened and that caused no problem so then they brought in mandatory drug testing thinking that's a good idea because we'll get people clean now but the problem is that cannabis stays in the system for sort of anything up to six weeks or so it's a very long kind of half life in in in in the blood and so so of course people
会想，哦天哪，我要被查出毒品阳性了，所以……但海洛因在系统中的停留时间只有两三天。所以突然间，我们从一个每个人都能接触到、可以抽大麻且不是大问题的系统，变成了一个海洛因在我们的监狱中成为巨大巨大问题的局面。那些进去的人无法获得大麻，但他们可以获得海洛因，所以他们开始……所以你绝对有成千上万的人在没有海洛因习惯的情况下进入监狱，却带着海洛因习惯出来，然后是长期的海洛因习惯，这给社会造成了巨大的附带损害和犯罪的附带成本，当然最终通常会导致他们再次
are oh dear i'm going to get i'm going to get a positive drug test so so but heroin only stays in the system for two or three days so suddenly we went from a system where everyone kind of had access to could smoke cannabis and it wasn't a big issue and the and the authorities turned the blind to a situation where heroin became a massive massive issue in our prisons and those people who went in couldn't get cannabis but they could get heroin so they start and so you absolutely have had thousands of people who have entered prison without a heroin habit and come out with a heroin habit and then a long-term heroin habit which cost society huge amounts in in collateral damage and collateral costs of crime and of course ultimately usually leads them back in
入狱。所以，在我看来，这是疯狂的。而且你知道，毒品只是物质，它们没有任何道德品质，它们仅仅是化学物质。我们选择如何监管这些物质的供应和分配，决定了它们造成多少危害。我们选择了最糟糕的路线，即几乎禁止一切，包括大麻，除了酒精作为一种致醉物。所以我们禁止了几乎所有其他形式的致醉物，即使是那些效果相对温和的。所以我们做了这些，结果我们做了什么？我们还加倍延长了刑期，所以我们同时加倍了毒品交易的刑期。我们做了所有这些，因为这显得对
inside yet again so so madness in my opinion and you know drugs are just substances they don't have any moral quality they are simply chemical substances and it's how we choose to regulate the supply and the distribution of those substances which dictates how much harm they cause and we've chosen the worst possible route which is prohibition of almost everything including cannabis and and excluding only really alcohol as a sort of an intoxicant so we we prohibited almost every other form of intoxicant even those which are relatively mild in their effect so so we've done that and what have we done as a result we've also doubled down on the length of sentences so we've doubled the length of sentences for drug dealing at the same time and we've done all of that because because it gets tough
毒品和毒贩很强硬。而且你知道，美国人现在在加勒比海炸毁船只，你知道，人们未经审判，因为他们说他们在贩运毒品。那能挽救巴尔的摩或奥克兰街头的一条生命吗？当然不能。这没有任何区别。如果它确实有区别，它只会让毒品稍微贵一点，稍微冒险一点，并在毒品和毒品交易的世界中制造更多的暴力。所以我们不断犯下这些同样的愚蠢错误，而实际上我们应该问自己，一如既往，也许这只是因为我的性格类型。但我总是问自己，我们怎样才能做得更好一点？更好的做法是什么？而不是什么做法最符合我们的先入之见
on drugs and drug dealers and you know the americans are now blowing up boats in the caribbean you know people without a trial because they're saying they're trafficking drugs is that going to save a life on the streets of Baltimore or Oakland? Of course not. It doesn't make any difference whatsoever. If it does make a difference, it makes the drug slightly more expensive, slightly more risky, and creates even more violence in the world of drugs and drug dealing. So we keep making these same stupid mistakes when actually we should be asking ourselves, as ever, and maybe it's just because of my personality type. But I'm always asking myself, how can we do it a bit better? What's the better way of doing it? Instead of what's the way that fits most with our preconceptions
和我们的偏见。当你作为一个社会被先入之见和偏见所引导时，你最终会变得一团糟。恐怕这就是我们目前在毒品问题上的处境。这太有趣了。而且我想我正在从几个不同的角度来看待这个问题，真的，心理学家的角度，我们知道当我们感觉某种方式时，我们要么想让自己兴奋起来，要么想让自己平静下来。这就是为什么物质对那些真正与强烈创伤、自我批评或只是，你知道，侵入性幻觉作斗争的人来说可能是变革性的。就像，你知道，这就是物质可以发挥作用的时候。所以如果我们能保护人们免受
and our prejudices. And when you're led by preconceptions and prejudice as a society, you end up pretty messed up. And that's, I'm afraid, in terms of drugs where we are right now. It's so, so interesting. And I think I'm kind of looking at this from a couple of different angles, really, the kind of psychologist angle where we know that when we're feeling a certain kind of way, we either want to bump ourselves up or we want to bump ourselves down. And that's where substances can be transformative for people that are really struggling with intense trauma or, you know, self-criticism or just, you know, intrusive visions. Like, you know, that's when substances can kind of come into their own. So if we can protect people from
以及我们的偏见。当一个社会被先入之见和偏见所引导时，最终会变得一团糟。恐怕这就是我们目前在毒品问题上的处境。这真的非常非常有趣。我想我正从几个不同的角度来看待这个问题，一个是心理学家的角度，我们知道当人们有某种感受时，要么想让自己兴奋起来，要么想让自己平静下来。这就是为什么对于那些真正饱受严重创伤、自我批评或侵入性幻觉困扰的人来说，物质可能会产生变革性的影响。这就是物质可以发挥作用的时候。所以，如果我们能保护人们免受
experiencing those traumas to begin with, then that's ideal. But yeah, like if we were to legalise that, then the shame, the blame, the kind of problems are reduced. But I'm also thinking about this as a parent, Chris. So I've got two boys. I know you've got quite a few children. And if it isn't illegal, you've got six of them. If it isn't illegal, I guess my fear is, God, they'll be out doing heroin, like, you know, and there's nothing I can do, there's nothing the police can do. It doesn't work like that? It doesn't work like that, doesn't it?
如果能从一开始就避免经历那些创伤，那当然是理想的。但确实，如果我们能将这些合法化，那么羞耻感、指责以及各种问题都会减少。但克里斯，我作为一个家长也在思考这个问题。我有两个儿子，我知道你有好几个孩子。如果你有六个孩子，如果这不违法，我的恐惧是，天哪，他们会出去吸食海洛因，你知道的，我对此无能为力，警察也无能为力。事情不是这样运作的吗？不是这样的，对吧？
Because first of all, of course, it would be illegal to supply drugs to under 18s, as it is to supply alcohol. But I accept that that doesn't stop under 18s getting hold of alcohol. But the reality is, if you had a legal supply chain, you would have different. different levels of control and access for different kinds of drugs. So for example, THC, or the main ingredient of Canada, is sort of THC vapes and THC edibles, et cetera, which are legal in many, many parts of the US now and some parts of Europe and other places.
因为首先，向18岁以下的人提供毒品当然是非法的，就像提供酒精一样。但我承认，这并不能阻止18岁以下的人获取酒精。但现实是，如果你有一个合法的供应链，你就会对不同种类的毒品有不同的控制和获取水平。例如，THC，也就是大麻的主要成分，现在在美国许多地方以及欧洲和其他一些地方，THC电子烟和THC食品等是合法的。
You know, you have a lower level of control over access to that, then you would have over access to heroin, particularly pharmaceutical, injectable pharmaceutical heroin. And so you're not legal, so it's really important, I think, to understand, Legalization on its own isn't the answer. You have to have legalization, you have to have licensing of sale and supply,
你知道，你对这些东西的获取控制水平较低，而对海洛因，特别是医用注射级海洛因的控制则会更严格。所以，我认为理解这一点非常重要：合法化本身并不是答案。你必须有合法化，必须有销售和供应的许可制度，
and you have to have regulations. That regulation, of course, is about quality control, it's about ensuring that labeling is correct and ensuring that, you know, that dosages are measurable and are measured in a scientific way, just as you have to do with the supply of alcohol. Every single bottle of whiskey has to declare upon it
而且你必须有监管。这种监管当然是关于质量控制的，是关于确保标签正确，并确保剂量是可测量的，且以科学的方式进行测量，就像你供应酒精时必须做的那样。每一瓶威士忌都必须在上面声明
exactly what's in it, exactly how much alcohol is in it, and every alcohol product that you buy has the same thing. With drugs, you would do exactly the same thing. Of course, you would still have health warnings, et cetera. But if you had a system like this, would it mean that the 15, 16 year olds would experiment with heroin more? I don't think it would. I honestly don't. Because the reason why young people sometimes do get hooked on heroin is because they're introduced to it by dealers who have a motive to get them hooked on heroin and want another customer for an indefinite period. Once you remove the sort of the illegal supply chain and everything is applied for a licensed kind of system,
里面到底有什么，酒精含量到底是多少，你购买的每一种酒精产品都有同样的要求。对于毒品，你也会做同样的事情。当然，你仍然会有健康警告等。但如果你有这样一个系统，这是否意味着15、16岁的孩子会更多地尝试海洛因？我不认为会。我真的不这么认为。因为年轻人有时会沉迷于海洛因的原因是，他们是被那些有动机让他们上瘾并希望长期拥有客户的毒贩引入歧途的。一旦你消除了那种非法供应链，一切都通过许可制度来供应，
them and no one's pushing drugs, but they're available. So those who do want to, for example, regularly use cannabis in some way, shape, or form and not smoke it because the smoking, of course, is terribly damaging to the help, to the health, but, but if they're at relatively low harm ways for it to ingest cannabis and people want to do that, who are we as a society to say they can't? I mean, what, what, why, what, what, what, what, what right do we have to say that you can't if what you're doing isn't harming anyone else. And I think the reality is that most young people would go through.
没有人会强迫推销毒品，但它们是可获得的。所以那些确实想要以某种形式定期使用大麻的人，而且不是通过吸食——因为吸食当然对健康极其有害——如果他们有相对低危害的方式来摄入大麻，而人们又想这样做，我们作为社会有什么权利说他们不能呢？我的意思是，如果他们的行为没有伤害到其他人，我们有什么权利说他们不能这样做？我认为现实是，大多数年轻人都会经历。
through a cycle of experimentation in exactly the same way as most of them do with alcohol. But interestingly, nowadays, of course, we're seeing young people increasingly rejecting alcohol and using it much less than was the case 20, 30 years ago. So these things come and go in patterns and cycles, which aren't necessarily to do with the supply chain, but to do with the way that young people are kind of,
经历一个实验周期，就像大多数人对待酒精一样。但有趣的是，如今我们看到年轻人越来越排斥酒精，使用量比20、30年前少得多。所以这些事情以模式和周期出现和消失，这不一定与供应链有关，而是与年轻人……
their culture is developing, including through social media, et cetera, and what popular isn't popular. But I don't, myself, I don't think for a moment, If you had a legal license and regulated, kids will be more at risk of trying heroin than they are now. I think they're much more at risk now. Because if they seek out cannabis, for example, they're going to be offered other drugs by the second dealer. Probably not always.
他们的文化发展方式有关，包括通过社交媒体等，以及什么是流行的，什么是不流行的。但我自己，我一点也不认为，如果你有合法的许可和监管，孩子们尝试海洛因的风险会比现在更大。我认为他们现在的风险要大得多。因为如果他们寻找大麻，他们很可能会被第二个毒贩提供其他毒品。可能不总是这样。
There are some people who just deal weed, I get that. But there are also those who very much use it as an opportunity to kind of try a bit of this, try a bit of that, try something else. And then you have a problem because all of that stuff is all mixed up. There's no real control as to what's in it or anything like that. I genuinely believe that in a licensed system, you would find that fewer young people would try the most dangerous drugs, maybe a slightly higher number would try cannabis in particular than try it now, but I'm not sure we'd make that a huge difference, because let's be honest, cannabis is available pretty freely anywhere in the UK.
有些人只卖大麻，我明白。但也有一些人非常乐于利用这个机会，让你尝试这个，尝试那个，尝试其他东西。然后你就有了麻烦，因为所有这些东西都混在一起了。对于里面到底有什么，没有任何真正的控制。我真诚地相信，在一个许可制度下，你会发现尝试最危险毒品的年轻人会更少，尝试大麻的人数可能会比现在稍微多一点，但我不敢肯定这会有巨大的差异，因为老实说，大麻在英国任何地方都相当容易获得。
I mean, you walk around London. I mean, it is almost like being in Amsterdam used to be, you know, 30 years ago. You know, the smell of cannabis is everywhere, and it's clearly extremely excess. Well, we know that, as a lawyer, I know that as a criminal lawyer, because one of the reasons is because of the invention of, you know, hydroponic systems and really, really efficient ways to grow cannabis. So we've moved our entire model from imported cannabis to homegrown cannabis, and we've largely moved on from physical cannabis being smoked into oils and bakes and other kinds of ways of consuming. So it we've moved, even in the illegal market, we've moved away from the most dangerous form of consumption, which is smoking. And we've moved towards other forms of consumption, such oils and liquids and edible, which are, you know, yes, they still have the psychological impact and the psychological effect, but they don't really damage your body particularly physically in the way that smoking does and did. So, so I, you know, in the end, let people make choices and also let young people, you know,
我的意思是，你在伦敦走一走。这几乎就像30年前的阿姆斯特丹。你知道，大麻的味道无处不在，而且显然非常容易获取。作为一名律师，我知道这一点，因为原因之一是水培系统的发明，以及种植大麻的高效方法。所以我们已经将整个模式从进口大麻转向了本土种植大麻，并且我们已经在很大程度上从吸食实体大麻转向了油、烘焙食品和其他消费方式。所以即使在非法市场，我们也已经远离了最危险的消费形式，即吸食。我们转向了其他消费形式，如油、液体和食品，它们确实仍有心理影响，但它们不像吸食那样对身体造成特别大的物理损害。所以，最终，让人们做出选择，也让年轻人……
would I be petrified at the thought of my kids trying ecstasy in a club? I'd be more petrified now than I would be if I knew that what the ecstasy they were taking, was the dosage was appropriate for their height, their weight, their side, and wasn't going to, wasn't going to cause them to end up dead in a hospital. So I'd be much rather they tried something in those circumstances than, for example, in the case of alcohol, you know, tried so illegally made alcohol that had all sorts of stuff in it and who knows what. I'd much rather they were drinking something that I knew what was in it and they can make a mistake, they can make mistake. And some of them, you know, yes, a proportion of those who use drugs,
如果想到我的孩子在夜店尝试摇头丸，我会感到恐惧吗？我现在会比我知道他们服用的摇头丸剂量适合他们的身高、体重，且不会导致他们死在医院里时更感到恐惧。所以我宁愿他们在那种情况下尝试某些东西，而不是像酒精那样，尝试非法制造的、含有各种乱七八糟成分的酒。我宁愿他们喝的是我知道成分的东西，他们可能会犯错，他们确实会犯错。而且他们中的一些人，是的，一部分使用毒品的人，
even in a license and legalized market, will have a problem with it, undoubtedly. But you also then have to ensure that you make accessible, you know, rehab and other forms of sort of therapeutic responses to real drug problems and psychosis in a way that at the moment we simply, we under-resource all of that provision. And many, many of those who have the worst forms of psychological and physical harms from drugs end up dead. And that to me is an utter tragedy and shows you once again why the system is so badly broken. Yeah, I think when I asked the question, I had forgotten about the licensable bit. I was still thinking about it being legal, but, you know, happening in an underpass.
即使在许可和合法化的市场中，也会遇到问题，毫无疑问。但你随后必须确保提供康复中心和其他形式的治疗性应对措施，以解决真正的毒品问题和精神病，而目前我们对所有这些服务的投入严重不足。许多遭受最严重心理和身体伤害的人最终死亡。对我来说，这完全是一场悲剧，再次向你展示了为什么这个系统如此糟糕地崩溃了。是的，我想当我问那个问题时，我忘记了许可的部分。我当时还在想它是合法的，但发生在地下通道里。
And that is not what we're talking about. Not what I'm advocating. No, and you know, anyone who said, make it a free-for-all, let anybody deal any drugs they want. I think that's just been safe. That would be, even worse than what we have met. Okay, I totally agree. Just before we finish, in case people are like, I don't even know what a barrister is, I don't even know what a KEC is.
那不是我们在谈论的。也不是我所倡导的。不，任何说“让它完全自由，让任何人随意交易任何毒品”的人，我认为那是不安全的。那甚至会比我们现在所拥有的更糟。好的，我完全同意。在我们结束之前，以防人们不知道什么是大律师，不知道什么是御用大律师（KC）。
Could you give us a very brief overview about what that is, Chris? Of course. So in my case, I'm a barrister. I was called to the bar in 1993, and that means that you've become someone who's entitled to wear a wig and a gown and all the costume that people will have seen on TV and in movies and so forth. And my job is basically to go to court and act in criminal cases. And in my case, I defend people accused of serious crimes.
你能给我们做一个非常简短的概述吗，克里斯？当然。就我而言，我是一名大律师。我于1993年获得执业资格，这意味着你成为了一名有权佩戴假发和长袍，以及人们在电视和电影中看到的那种服装的人。我的工作基本上是去法庭处理刑事案件。就我而言，我为被指控犯有严重罪行的人辩护。
And I'm the one that does the trial. I'm the one that cross-examines the witnesses and makes the speeches to the jury and tries to persuade the jury to my side of the case, which in my case is defence. I've always done defence. I don't do prosecution cases. So I'm basically a criminal defence lawyer, a trial lawyer. And a KC is simply the most senior member of the profession of barrisers. And it stands for King's Council.
我是负责审判的人。我是那个盘问证人、向陪审团发表陈词，并试图说服陪审团站在我这一边的人，在我的案件中，也就是辩护方。我一直做辩护。我不处理检方案件。所以我基本上是一名刑事辩护律师，一名出庭律师。而KC只是大律师职业中最资深的成员。它代表“国王法律顾问”。
And it's an appointment which you can apply for. Any barrister after a certain period can apply to become a KC. if you're appointed, it means that essentially you are in the top 10% in terms of the profession in terms of quality standards and everything else. So KCs are essentially as a brand. We are the most senior and the most expert barristers or trial lawyers in my case in the country. And our job is, you know, as casees, we tend to only deal with extremely complex and serious cases. Or in my case, many of my cases are quite high profile cases, actually, for the celebrities or very wealthy people. You know, that's the world in which
这是一个你可以申请的任命。任何大律师在一段时间后都可以申请成为KC。如果你被任命，这意味着你基本上在职业质量标准等方面处于前10%。所以KC本质上是一个品牌。我们是全国最资深、最专业的出庭律师。我们的工作是，作为KC，我们往往只处理极其复杂和严重的案件。或者就我而言，我的许多案件实际上是相当引人注目的案件，针对名人或非常富有的人。你知道，这就是我所处的世界，
operate and that's the world which pays for this big garden. And it is a beautiful garden. I think I've been hearing ladders and tractors and birds. Like, there's been a lot going on, but it is. The gardener decided to bring out his, to bring out his little tractors. It is absolutely beautiful. Chris, if people want to learn more about you, your work, your chambers. Where's the best place for them to do that? Well, the most place is crystalkc.com, which has got everything about me. It's got all of the different things I do, not just my legal work. It has a lot of details some of the cases I've been involved in, the high profile stuff. It has a lot of access to a lot of the writing I've done,
也是支付这个大花园费用的世界。这确实是一个美丽的花园。我想我一直听到梯子、拖拉机和鸟叫声。有很多事情在发生，但它确实很美。克里斯，如果人们想了解更多关于你、你的工作、你的律师事务所的信息，最好的地方在哪里？嗯，最好的地方是crystalkc.com，上面有关于我的一切。它有我做的所有不同事情，不仅仅是我的法律工作。它有很多我参与过的案件的细节，那些高调的案件。它有很多我写过的文章的访问权限，
journalistic pieces that I've done. And it gives you access through to my YouTube channel, Crystal KC's YouTube, which has lots of mentoring stuff for young people, career stuff, as well as sort of policy and stuff like that. So on the whole, I would just say go to crystalkasey got.com and you can also follow me on X and LinkedIn. Amazing. I have loved our chat. It's been five years in the making, but it's been everything I needed it to be and more.
我做过的新闻报道。它还让你能访问我的YouTube频道，Crystal KC's YouTube，上面有很多针对年轻人的指导内容、职业建议，以及政策等方面的内容。所以总的来说，我会说去crystalkc.com，你也可以在X和LinkedIn上关注我。太棒了。我非常喜欢我们的谈话。这花了五年时间才促成，但它是我所需要的一切，甚至更多。
Thank you so much for your time. I will make sure everything is linked. And I would just like to say, if you found this interesting, please do buy, read, listen to Crystal Casey's book, which is called Justice on Trial because it's so interesting. Thank you so much for your time, Chris. You know, the talk has been fascinating and thank you for being so interested
非常感谢你的时间。我会确保一切都链接上。我只想说，如果你觉得这很有趣，请一定要购买、阅读、收听Crystal KC的书，书名叫《正义审判》（Justice on Trial），因为它非常有趣。非常感谢你的时间，克里斯。你知道，这次谈话非常引人入胜，谢谢你如此感兴趣，
and thank you for, you know, showing that Milton Keynes can have the odd success story. Yes, indeed it can. Thank you again for your time. Thank you so much to our incredible guest for today. If you have found this helpful, please do drop some support into the comments, like the video. And yeah, let me know what your take. home points are. If you're listening on Spotify, you can comment, you can ask questions, you can support the episode, you can tell us what you think, and if you're on Apple, please do
也谢谢你展示了米尔顿凯恩斯（Milton Keynes）也能有偶尔的成功故事。是的，确实可以。再次感谢你的时间。非常感谢我们今天不可思议的嘉宾。如果你觉得这有帮助，请在评论区留下支持，点赞视频。是的，让我知道你的收获。如果你在Spotify上收听，你可以评论，可以提问，可以支持这一集，可以告诉我们你的想法，如果你在Apple上，请一定要
rate and review. It just, you know, it really connects with me as an idea, and I think being so trauma-informed myself as a clinician, it's hard not to see trauma everywhere. What do you think I would love to know. Have you read the book? Has this encouraged you to read the book? I love it on audible. I've listened twice, as I think I did say in episode as well. We've got a little special mini series on crime and justice. I think it's next week we've got an episode scheduled with a clinical psychologist working in justice systems and with another member of her team as well as we discuss what it's really like to be released from prison and what the rehab and release processes are like. So if you found this episode helpful, I think you will find the next
评分和评论。这真的让我产生共鸣，作为一名临床医生，我自己也非常了解创伤，很难不随处看到创伤。你觉得呢？我很想知道。你读过这本书吗？这是否鼓励你去读这本书？我喜欢在Audible上听。我想我在这一集中也说过，我已经听了两遍。我们有一个关于犯罪和正义的小型特别系列。我想下周我们安排了一集，邀请了一位在司法系统中工作的临床心理学家和她团队的另一名成员，我们将讨论从监狱释放出来的真实感受，以及康复和释放过程是什么样的。所以如果你觉得这一集有帮助，我想你会发现下一集
one really helpful too. If you are an aspiring psych and you love sessions like this, I think you'll really, really like the aspiring psychologist membership. Do check out the details in the show notes or in the description. And if you like helping people you work with to understand trauma and grief and depression and why it affects us in the way it does, please do check out the Our Tricky Brain Kit at www. Aspiring-psychologist.com. You can get an exclusive
也真的很有帮助。如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，并且喜欢这样的环节，我想你会非常非常喜欢“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”。请查看节目说明或描述中的详细信息。如果你喜欢帮助你共事的人理解创伤、悲伤和抑郁，以及为什么它们以这种方式影响我们，请务必查看我们的“棘手大脑工具包”（Our Tricky Brain Kit），网址是www.Aspiring-psychologist.com。你可以获得独家
YouTube discount, 10 pounds off, with the code YouTube 10. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast, that's your side. You'll be on your way to being qualified. I'm a Psychologist podcast with Dr. Mary and Trent. Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton.
YouTube折扣，使用代码YouTube 10可减免10英镑。如果你正在寻求成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。有了这个播客，这就是你的伙伴。你将走上获得资格的道路。我是心理学家播客，主持人是Mary和Trent博士。嗨，我叫Emily。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。
I bought the book of the Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications, and I'm very. so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get onto the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was and using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我买了《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书，以帮助自己为第一轮博士申请做准备，我非常高兴我这么做了。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程非常有启发性，它给了我很多关于我自己的旅程和技能的反思。它也有助于把事情看得更透彻，并提醒我，如果我今年没有考上博士，那也没关系。然而，这本书最意想不到的乐趣是，每个人的旅程是多么鼓舞人心，每天早上用这些故事作为我的动力真是太愉快了。我几乎不舍得读完。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。